Hey guys, it's another SmartLess episode, we've done a lot of these intros, here's another one, it's going to be really fast, because we really kind of want to get to it, nobody wants to wait anymore. If you want it to be quick, just say this is SmartLess. He got me. Jay was a little late today, but it's no big deal. We've all had it. I've got to get one of those cars that go up, that would be nice. That would go above the traffic. It's the worst, it's the worst feeling.
大家好，又是一期 SmartLess 播客，我们做过很多这种开场白了，这是又一个，而且会非常快，因为我们真的很想直接进入正题，现在已经没人愿意再等了。如果你想快点，那就说这就是 SmartLess。他把我给套进去了。杰今天稍微迟到了一会儿，不过没关系。我们都遇到过这种情况。我也得去买一辆能飞起来的车，那可就太好了。那样就能飞到交通堵塞的上方了。那种感觉太糟糕了，简直是世上最糟糕的感觉。
I actually had to go to a thing this morning out here, all jokes aside, and it was like, there's never traffic here in the morning, because it's winter time. There was like, I couldn't, and it turned out there was a road closed. On Long Island you're talking about? I couldn't make this left turn, and from a certain point I went like, oh this is a joke, how am I ever going to make this turn? Did you have a daughter that got a flat tire on the way to school, and you had to double back and pick her up? No, is that what happened? No. Yeah, I had to do two separate trips to two different schools.
说实话，抛开玩笑不谈，我今天早上得去外面办点事，结果发现这里早上居然从来没有堵过车，因为现在是冬天。我简直无法通过，结果发现是有一条路封了。你是说在长岛吗？我无法左转，从某个时刻起我就在想，噢，这简直是个笑话，我怎么可能转得过去？难道你有个女儿在去学校的路上爆胎了，你不得不折返回去接她？没有，是那样吗？没有。对，我不得不分两趟去两所不同的学校。
GB, just breathe, just breathe. And I'm all hopped up on coffee, so I already want to kill somebody. No, no, no, no, just breathe. We're all together, we're all together. Do they make a non-violent caffeine? You mean violent to make you violent, or violent for your bowels? Yeah, both. You know, I actually have cut down on my amount of coffee before I play golf, because I get too angry at bad shots,
GB，冷静点，深呼吸。而且我喝咖啡喝得有点亢奋，所以我现在就想杀个人。不，不，不，不，深呼吸。我们都在一起，我们都在一起。他们有没有生产无暴力含咖啡因的东西？你是说会让你有暴力倾向的，还是对肠胃有暴力的？对，两者都有。你知道吗，其实我在打高尔夫球之前已经减少了咖啡的摄入量，因为我对打得烂的球太容易生气了，
which I make a lot of. No. Caffeine is supposed to make you, like, not angry, it's supposed to make you like, energetic. No, it's not supposed to make you angry, but it gives you energy, and if you start to feel of... I just had some. Yeah? Well, he had a tea with sugar, so it was a vessel for the sugar that he wanted. So, do you have, what's the latest, you'll have a cup of coffee now, Jay, in the day?
而我偏偏经常打出烂球。不对。咖啡不是应该让你，比如说，不生气吗，它应该让你觉得精力充沛。不对，它不是让你生气的，但它能给你能量，如果你开始感觉到……我刚才刚喝了一些。是吗？好吧，他喝了一杯加糖的茶，所以那茶只是他想要摄入糖分的一个容器。那么，你现在一天会喝几杯咖啡，杰？
Right now. I've tried to go to a green tea caffeine stimulant in the afternoon, because I feel like it's less intense. Yeah. What about a nice sleepy time to you at night? Sure. All right. Sure. I mean, okay.
就现在。我下午尝试改喝绿茶中的咖啡因兴奋剂了，因为我觉得它没那么强烈。那晚上来杯不错的助眠茶怎么样？当然。好吧。当然。我是说，好吧。
Do they make it in a gummy? They do. They do. They make a chamomile gummy. Well, from what I've heard, yeah, it's out there. Yeah. Okay. I'm going to take one minute to show you a picture that my sister got me.
他们有做成软糖的吗？有的。有的。他们生产洋甘菊软糖。嗯，据我所听说的，对，市面上是有的。对。好吧。我要花一分钟时间给你们看一张我姐姐弄给我的照片。
Wait, one second. He's going to take off his headphones, stand up, leave the microphone. We're already 15 minutes late. He's walking away from them. This better be amazing. And he knows we're doing an audio show, right? He's stopping everything for a picture. Here we go.
等等，一秒钟。他要摘下耳机，站起来，离开麦克风了。我们已经迟到15分钟了。他居然走开了。这最好是个惊艳的东西。而且他知道我们在做音频节目，对吧？他为了张照片把一切都暂停了。我们这就来看看。
No, no. My sister just sent me this picture of my family that was drawn when we were kids, and I remember sitting for it. She's like, I'm going to throw this out. Do you want it? I'm like, yeah, send it. So my sister got me a hand drawing of the whole family and they drew my mom's eye like a glass. Like it was the one opportunity he had to draw regular eyes. Yeah.
不，不。我姐姐刚刚给我发了这张我家的照片，这是我们小时候画的，我还记得当时坐着当模特的情景。她说：“我打算把这个扔了。你还要吗？”我说：“要啊，发给我吧。”所以 我姐姐给我弄来了一张全家福的手绘图，他们把我妈妈的眼睛画得像个玻璃球一样。就好像这是他唯一一次画正常眼睛的机会。对。
But he didn't. I wish you could see it. I'll show it to you next time. Where is it? It's in the closet here. Okay. Anyway, who cares? It was really funny because it's like.
但他没画好。我真希望你们能看到。下次我拿给你们看。在哪儿？就在这边的衣柜里。好吧。不管怎样，谁在乎呢？真的很好笑，因为就像是……
No, we're definitely going to talk after this. But you think it's like the one opportunity somebody has to draw her two normal eyes and he went ahead and made an effort to make sure that's that eye. Well, maybe for him as an artist, maybe it was important for him to be authentic. Yeah, to be really representative. And you know what I mean, Sean, did you ever think about the artist? How dare you? And maybe he had some baggage. Maybe he had some baggage with your mom. Maybe maybe really having a thing as her chance. Look this off at her.
不，我们录完之后绝对要聊聊这个。但你觉得这就像是某人有机会把她画成两只正常的眼睛，结果他却偏偏特意确保把那只眼睛画成那样。好吧，也许对作为艺术家的他来说，保持真实可能很重要。对，要有真正的代表性。你知道我的意思吗，肖恩，你有没有想过这位艺术家？你怎么敢？也许他背负着什么包袱。也许他对你妈妈有什么心结。也许他真的觉得这是他的机会，以此来恶心她一把。
Okay, we're not going to make our guests wait any longer. Okay. So guys, totally lost for words for this one is huge. If picking guests was a competition, which it's not not, I feel like I might be the winner today. It's the written portion. This is the written portion. He's at the top of his game in his field. But more importantly, I've heard that is that good old Coca Cola is a drink of choice, which is something we have in common.
好了，我们不能再让嘉宾等下去了。好了。伙计们，对此我简直无言以对，这个咖位太大了。如果挑选嘉宾是一场比赛——虽然其实并不是，但我感觉我今天可能会是赢家。这是写好的台词部分。这是写好的部分。他在他所处的领域处于巅峰状态。但更重要的是，我听说那好喝的古老可口可乐是他的首选饮品，这也是我们共同的爱好。
That's all I drink is Coca Cola. Born in Cincinnati, Ohio, raised in Arizona. He fell in love with filmmaking at a very young age. He was the youngest director to be signed to a major Hollywood studio long term. Is this Steven Spielberg? We've had many successful folks on this podcast, but I don't think anyone that's had an Oscar nomination in six different decades. Scott and I just saw his new film. We're obsessed.
我喝的全是可口可乐。出生于俄亥俄州辛辛那提，在亚利桑那州长大。他在很小的时候就爱上了电影制作。他是与好莱坞大制片厂签下长期合同的最年轻的导演。这是史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格吗？我们这档播客上过很多成功人士，但我觉得没有人曾在整整六个不同的十年里都获得过奥斯卡提名。我和斯科特刚刚看了他的新电影。我们简直着迷了。
Guys, it's the goat, Mr. Steven Spielberg. Are you kidding me? I made Steven Spielberg wait 15 minutes. Good Lord. By the way, look at this. Oh, look at that. Well, why did you, how did you know that? Because I could see how nervous you were.
伙计们，这就是史上最佳（GOAT），史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格先生。你在开玩笑吧？我让史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格等了15分钟。天哪。顺便说一句，看这个。哦，看看那个。好吧，你为什么，你怎么知道的？因为我能看出你有多紧张。
And I just thought, of course, the only person who's going to make you nervous like this is Steven Spielberg. Yeah, absolutely. Wow, Steven, how great have you been? God, I hope this was worth waiting for. I am so sorry. These kids, these kids, I recommend not having them. They'll make you late for things. No, don't worry about it, please.
我当时就想，理所当然，唯一能让你紧张成这样的人就是史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格。没错，绝对是。哇，史蒂芬，你最近怎么样？天哪，我希望这没有白等。我太抱歉了。这些孩子，这些孩子，我建议别生。他们会让你干什么都迟到。不，别担心，请坐。
I'm just happy to be with all of you. Likewise. Thank you for doing this. It's such an honor that you're here. So thank you. What an honor. Wow. I meant it.
我只是很高兴能和大家在一起。彼此彼此。谢谢你抽空来。你能来真是我们的荣幸。所以谢谢你。真是莫大的荣幸。哇。我是认真的。
Scott and I saw the Fablemans the day it came out. And the only other time in recent memory I've enjoyed sitting in a theater that much was watching West Side Story last year. You did speak highly of that. Which I wrote you about and I gushed. Which I loved. As a matter of fact, I reread the letter this morning. Oh, thank you again. Well, thanks.
我和斯科特在《造梦之家》上映的那天就去看了。我记忆中最近唯一一次在电影院坐得这么爽的，就是去年看《西区故事》的时候。你确实对那部片子评价很高。我还给你写了信，赞不绝口。我超爱那部电影。事实上，我今天早上还重读了那封信呢。哦，再次谢谢你。不客气。
Yeah, it was. That was awesome. I can't wait to see the Fablemans. It's so good. Which makes me think just right out of the gate. Are you an avid movie? Do you go to the movies still? And is there anything you like recently?
对，那真是太棒了。我迫不及待想看《造梦之家》了。太棒了。这让我想到了一个问题：你是一个狂热的电影爱好者吗？你现在还去看电影吗？最近有什么你喜欢的作品吗？
I do go to the movies. Sometimes not a movie theater per se during the pandemic. So I was starved from the movie theater experiences. All of us were for over two years. But you keep up. Yeah. Once it broke. The first movie I saw, the first movie I went to a theater to see was Nope.
我确实去看电影。疫情期间有时并不算真正去电影院的那种。所以我对电影院的体验渴望已久。我们所有人都有两年多时间这样了。但你一直关注着。对。一旦解封了。我去看的第一部电影，去电影院看的第一部电影是《不！》。
That was the first. That sort of broke my fast. And I went in to see it in New York. So that was the first movie. He's an exciting filmmaker. No, but not of Planet Earth as we found out is what it stands for. True story. Yeah.
那是第一部。那算是打破了我的禁忌。我去纽约看的。所以那是第一部电影。他是个令人兴奋的电影制片人。不是的，正如我们所知，它代表的不来自地球。真实的故事。对。
Did you know that, Stephen? I did not know that. I should know that because I am not of Planet Earth either. And I should know my brother. Now, Stephen, can I ask you, you hear that directors have to manage not only the process of making a film and the whole team that's assembled, but also their expectations as far as what they imagined versus what is happening and then what is ultimately you're left with as far as the finished product.
你知道这件事吗，史蒂芬？我不知道。我应该知道的，因为我也不是来自地球的。我应该了解我的同胞。现在，史蒂芬，我可以问你吗，你听说导演们不仅要管理拍电影的过程以及组建的整个团队，还要管理他们的期望——他们想象的与正在发生的之间的差距，以及最终呈现在你面前的成品。
Something as close to your life as this particular film is, I would imagine those stakes were even higher. So did the Fableman's turn out exactly the way that you wanted? We know something. None of my films turn out exactly the way I wanted. I don't think that's possible for anybody to achieve, no matter how much time and heart and budget they put in. This is a team process.
对于这样一部与你的生活如此贴近的特定电影，我想象这种赌注甚至更高。那么《造梦之家》最终呈现出来的效果完全符合你的预期吗？我们都知道。我的电影没有哪部是完全按我想要的样子呈现的。我觉得任何人都不可能做到这一点，不管他们投入了多少时间、心血和预算。这是一个团队合作的过程。
Because it's a process that the vision is, by the way, I really think it's not distilled by having so many collaborators, it's enhanced through collaboration, so the more talented people who help you tell your story, the better the story is going to be told. So I'm a big believer in that. But at the same time, I have a kind of high bar that is real hard for me to really reach at, and especially with the Fableman's, because one of the high bars in this movie were my three sisters, and I figured if I pass muster with them, because my mom and dad are no longer with us, but if they liked the movie, I was going to be okay.
因为这是一个愿景的过程，顺便说一句，我真的认为它不会因为有这么多合作者而被冲淡，反而会通过合作得到增强，所以帮助你讲故事的才华横溢的人越多，故事就会讲得越好。所以我非常坚信这一点。但与此同时，我有一个很高的标准，对我来说真的很难达到，尤其是对《造梦之家》而言，因为这部电影的几个高标准之一就是我的三个姐姐，我想只要我能通过她们那一关——因为我父母已经不在了——但只要她们喜欢这部电影，我就觉得没问题了。
Right? And if my wife liked the movie, I was going to be doubly okay. But this wasn't the kind of movie that I thought I was making for the masses. This was something, as I've said, this was $40 million of therapy. Which is about how much it costed anyway. Yeah, maybe that's how much it costed. I've never been in therapy except one time to try to get out of the army when I was 18 years old, and my dad said, well, you can go see my psychiatrist, and maybe he'll write
对吧？如果我妻子也喜欢这部电影，我觉得就会双倍没问题。但这并不是那种我认为自己是为大众拍的电影。正如我所说，这是价值4000万美元的心理治疗。反正差不多也就是这个造价。对，也许这就是花费吧。我从来没有做过心理治疗，除了有一次为了在我18岁时逃避服兵役，我爸说：“好吧，你可以去看看我的精神科医生，也许他会给你写……”
you a letter, and I saw him about five times, and then he was actually pro the Vietnam War and wouldn't write me the letter. No way. That was the last time I actually was in therapy. I'll teach you. But no, this was, I didn't have big expectations in terms of people understanding this, thinking that I was making a movie, obviously making an autobiographical movie about key moments of my formative years, of growing up inside a very unusual family, until people started
“……一封信”，我看了他大约五次，然后他其实是个支持越南战争的人，不肯给我写那封信。不会吧。那是最后一次我真正做心理治疗。我让你长长记性。但不是的，这其实是，对于人们能否理解这一点，我并没有抱太大期望，以为我只是在拍一部电影，显然是一部关于我的形成期的关键时刻的自传电影，关于在一个非常不寻常的家庭中长大的经历，直到人们开始……
seeing the movie and telling me how they felt about the film, and then immediately telling me about the similarities about their childhoods and the divorces and the bullying and the anti-Semitism, and suddenly all these notes and letters and emails and texts came pouring in, and I actually felt like I wasn't alone anymore. I felt like I was in great company. How great. My story wasn't so unique after all. Well, which by the way is a great lesson.
看这部电影并告诉我他们对这部电影的感受，然后立即向我讲述关于他们的童年、离婚、霸凌以及反犹太主义的相似经历，突然间，所有这些便条、信件、电子邮件和短信如潮水般涌来，我其实觉得我不再孤单了。我觉得我找到了很好的伴侣。太棒了。我的故事毕竟不是那么独一无二。顺便说一句，这也是一个很好的教训。
I think that all of us go through as we get older, we start to recognize, if we can look for the similarities in other people, then we can start to recognize how not unique we are as people, and certainly that's been part of my journey. But did you ever have, or do you continue to have moments when you make a film that is semi-autobiographical, that does incorporate these key moments from your life, did you ever have moments where you wake up and you have almost like a panic of like, oh gosh, that was so revealing, or does it catch up with you in moments that you don't expect ever?
我认为我们所有人随着年龄的增长都会经历这一点，我们开始认识到，如果我们能寻找其他人身上的相似之处，我们就能开始意识到作为人类的我们是多么的不独特，当然这也成为了我人生旅程的一部分。但是你有没有过，或者说当你制作一部半自传性质的电影、确实融入了你生活中的这些关键时刻时，你会不会继续有这样的时刻：你醒来时几乎会有一种恐慌感，觉得“天哪，这也太暴露了吧”，或者它会在你意想不到的时刻向你袭来？
I told the cast before we started shooting that I had gotten all my emotion out writing the script with Tony Kushner, because Tony was like my therapist on this, and there were so many times that we were writing this, and it would just be too hard. And then we'd step away, and I'd have to step away and come back, and Tony was brilliant with me, and so was Katie, my wife, and so I thought I got over the hardest part of telling the story and the telling of the story on paper. And then I said, this is a cast, that I'm going to be fine, don't worry about me, just get to know the characters you're playing, and let's all do this together as a family.
我在开拍前告诉演员们，我在和托尼·库什纳写剧本的时候已经把所有的情绪都宣泄光了，因为托尼在创作上就像我的心理医生一样，在编写这个剧本的过程中有很多次，真的太难了。然后我们会停下来，我不得不停下来再回来，托尼对我都很好，我的妻子凯蒂也是，所以我以为我已经克服了讲述这个故事最困难的部分，也就是在纸上讲述故事的部分。然后我说，这是一群演员，我会没事的，不用担心我，只要去了解你们扮演的角色，让我们像一家人一样一起完成这个任务。
And then on the first day of shooting, literally the first day, and I had seen all the actors individually in hair and makeup, of course, and Mark Bridges did great costumes on it, and so Mark said the cast is coming out, and so Michelle Williams and Paul Dano playing Burt and Mitzi, or Arnold and Leah, my parents, they came out and I was talking to somebody else, and I guess they were standing behind me until I finished my conversation. And I turned around, and I looked at them together, as certainly as Burt and Mitzi, but really I turned around, and there was my mom and my dad, and I completely lost it after that whole preamble to the cast, I'm going to be fine, I'm strong, I got all my
然后就在开拍的第一天，字面意义上的第一天，当然我已经在发型和化妆间分别见过所有的演员了，马克·布里奇斯在服装上做得非常好，马克说演员们要出来了，然后扮演伯特和米齐（也就是我父母阿诺德和莉娅）的米歇尔·威廉姆斯和保罗·达诺走了出来，我当时正在和别人说话，我想他们一直站在我身后，直到我结束谈话。我转过身去，看着他们站在一起，当然他们看起来就是伯特和米齐，但实际上我一转身，看到的就是我的爸爸妈妈，在对演员们发表了那一长串“我会没事的，我很坚强，我在写剧本时已经宣泄了所有情绪”的开场白之后，我彻底情绪崩溃了，他们立刻……
emotion out writing the script, I just totally lost it, and they immediately, Michelle ran to me, and she hugged me here, and Paul came behind me, and he hugged me there, and it was the beginning of a beautiful three months of- Wow, did you really, in the movie, little Sammy is filming his parents' divorce? Yes. Like when they get, did that really happen, did you have a camera filming your parents' divorcing? Well, I wasn't, no, I wasn't, you talked about the scene with the divorce.
米歇尔朝我跑过来，她在这里拥抱了我，保罗走到我身后，在那里拥抱了我，而那只是美好的三个月的开始——哇，在电影里，小萨米真的在拍摄他父母离婚的场景吗？是的。就像他们那样，那真的发生过吗？你真的有一台摄像机在拍摄你父母离婚吗？嗯，我不是，不，不是的，你说的那个关于离婚的场景。
Yeah. The announcement, no, no, no, that was in Sammy's mind, that's happening in Sammy's mind. Okay, okay. Sammy is going through something which we all went through, my sisters and I, that actually happened, my parents, they made an announcement, they announced that they were separating and getting a divorce. Wow.
对。那个宣布的过程，不，不，不，那是在萨米的脑海里，那是在萨米的脑海中发生的。好吧，好吧。萨米正在经历一些我们所有人都经历过的事情，我和我的姐姐们，那确实发生过，我的父母，他们做出了一个宣布，他们宣布他们分居并要离婚了。哇。
So, in my imagination, years later, telling the story, I imagine wouldn't, I need to get away from the trauma by putting a camera between myself and the event, so Sammy looks up and reflected in the mirror, Sammy imagines himself with the camera up to his eyes filming the divorce. Right, right, right. And that was Sammy's way of disassociation. Sean, Sean, when you saw that, sorry, just that you picked up on that, did it, what kind of effect did it have on you, because your parents got divorced, did it resonate with
所以，在我的想象中，多年后在讲述这个故事时，我想象着难道我不需要通过在自己和事件之间架起一台摄像机来逃离创伤吗？所以萨米抬起头，在镜子的反射中，萨米想象自己举起摄像机对着自己的眼睛拍摄父母离婚。对，对，对。这就是萨米解离的方式。肖恩，肖恩，当你看到那一幕时，抱歉，既然你注意到了，它对你产生了什么样的影响？因为你的父母也离婚了，它引起了你的共鸣吗？
you? Oh my God, I'm the only one in the theater that clapped, no, I'm kidding. No, when my dad laughed, we were like, ah, alleluia. But, no, no, it was very touching, for all the reasons you said, it really resonated with me on so many levels, the bullying, the divorce, the family interaction, like all of it, I was like, oh my God, that's me, that's me, that's me. But there's this beat at the very end of the movie, which I think is so clever, and everybody in the theater erupted with knowing laughter, the very, very, very last shot, the thing
哦，天哪，我是电影院里唯一一个鼓掌的人，不，开玩笑的。不，当我爸爸笑的时候，我们都在想，啊，哈利路亚。但是，不，不，那一幕非常感人，出于你所说的所有原因，它在很多层面上都与我产生了共鸣，霸凌、离婚、家庭互动，所有这些，我都觉得，哦，天哪，那是我，那是我，那是我。但电影的结尾处有一个非常巧妙的节拍，电影院里的每个人都发出会心的笑声，最后一个镜头，你在最后做的那件事——我不想剧透——实在是太巧妙了，我太喜欢了。
that you do at the end, which I don't want to give away, is so clever, I loved it. But it's also one of those moments that you are known for, where you trust that comedy or levity that you're bringing to a moment is going to work and not be cheesy or undercut the importance of the scene, it's such a fine line, and every movie, there's even in Schindler's List, there was like one line that was just a little comical from I think Ben Kingsley or somebody, and it was, you always ride that line, and how do you trust that that's going to work? Well, what I trust is that the audience remembers the movie I made, you know, that the audience
但这也是那种你所擅长的时刻，你相信自己带给某个时刻的喜剧效果或轻松感会发挥作用，而不会显得矫揉造作或削弱场景的重要性，这是一条非常微妙的界限，每一部电影都是如此，甚至在《辛德勒的名单》里，我也觉得本·金斯利或某个人有一句稍微有点滑稽的台词，而且你总是游走在这条线上，你是怎么相信这会管用的？好吧，我相信的是观众还记得我拍的电影，你知道的，观众记得足够清楚，如果我回忆起某些事情，那是可以被回忆起来的，你知道的，如果观众不理解萨米和他的偶像之间那最后一场大戏的要旨，如果他们没有听懂其中蕴含的教训，那就会对观众的聋耳产生影响，但当观众全神贯注时，我相信观众会跟上一切，他们会明白那个小尾声就是我试图表达的观点，我倾听了，我倾听了萨米这个角色的心声，而那一幕在现实生活中确实发生在我身上。我16、17岁时见到了大师，据我回忆，那一幕真的是一字不差地发生了。
remembers it well enough that if I recall something, it will be recallable, you know, if the audience didn't understand the gist of that last big scene between Sammy and his hero, and if they didn't listen to the content of the lesson, that would have fallen on a deaf ears of an audience, but when an audience pays attention, I just trust the audience follows everything, and that they're going to understand that that little coda was the point that I was trying to make, that I listened, that I listened to the character of Sammy, and that scene actually happened to me in real life. I met the master when I was like 16, 17 years old, and that word for word, to the best of
当他说“现在给老子滚出我的办公室”时，我太喜欢了。那就是他的原话。真有史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格的风格。所以，史蒂芬，这个故事一直留在你的脑海里，从你小时候起就伴随着你，我想你一定很长时间以来一直在重新构思把它拍成电影的想法。我想知道为什么偏偏是去年，你终于决定把它拍出来了？是因为其他项目的档期问题，当时还没完全准备好，还是因为什么原因？
my recollection, that word for word would have happened. When he says, now get the fuck out of my office, I love that. That's exactly what he says. So little Steven Spielberg. So Steven, this story has been in your mind and with you since you were a kid, and I would imagine you've been revisiting the idea of doing this for a long, long time. What was it about last year, I guess, when you finally decided to do it? Was it just timing of other projects, kind of not yet fully ready, or what was it?
不，挺有意思的。那是新冠疫情期间。那是闲置了几年的结果。那是无法去办公室的日子，导演工作是一种社交疾病。而写作有点像作家写作或艺术家画作那样。那是你可以从家里做的事情。我所有的作家朋友在整个疫情期间都在工作。我本质上是一个导演。
No, it was interesting. It was the COVID pandemic. It was sitting idle for a couple of years. It was not going into the office, and directing is a social disease. And writing is something that's kind of like when writers write or artists paint. It's something that you can do from home. All my writer friends kept working throughout the entire pandemic. I'm essentially a director.
我也是一个编剧兼导演，但我认同自己是一个导演。那是一种社交上的饥饿感，无法去办公室，无法和所有作家朋友们亲自坐在编剧室里开会。Zoom对我的效果不太好。而且我也感到非常恐慌，觉得这是世界末日，是一场史诗级别的事件，是一场发生在世界上的物种大灭绝事件。等我和托尼坐下来认真开始讨论撰写这个剧本时，我们已经失去了25万因新冠去世的美国人。
I'm also a writer director, but I identify as a director. And it was a social starvation, not being able to go into the office, not being able to sit around at a writer's room with all the writers in person. Zoom wasn't quite working for me. And I kind of also was terrified that this was an end of days, an epic level event, an extinction level event that was happening to the world. By the time Tony and I sat down to seriously start engaging in discussions about writing this, we'd already lost 250,000 Americans to COVID.
我当时实际上对凯蒂和我的家人说，如果有什么东西是我想要留下的，如果我有机会再拍最后一部电影，那会是什么电影？甚至连眼睛都没眨一下，它就会是这个故事。太酷了。你知道，执导《世界末日》的詹姆斯·格雷说过这样的话，我大概转述一下：在疫情期间，我们被关了两年，每个人都变得非常内省。这就是为什么现在上映的这些电影都这么私人化。他还说，但我觉得这是因为我们以为这一切都结束了。
And I actually was saying to Katie and my family, if there was one thing I wanted to leave behind, if I got a chance to make one more movie, what would that movie be? And without even blinking, it was going to be the story. That's cool. You know, James Gray, who directed Armageddon Times, said something like, and I'm paraphrasing, during the pandemic, we were locked away for two years, and everybody got very introspective. And that's why all these movies now coming out are personal. And he said, but I think it's because we think it's all over.
我们以为这将是我们拍的最后一部电影，所以他们才在拍这些。你对此有什么看法？你知道，我从来没有过这种感觉，直到现在，直到疫情期间，因为我一直在看着那种眼神，和我们所有人一样，我被福奇的报告深深吸引了。当时我被各大新闻媒体上所有主播所说的话以及所有出现的专家、还有白宫对这并没有那么严重的否认所深深吸引。
We think this is always our last movie we're ever going to make, and that's why they're making these. What are your thoughts about that? You know, I've never had that feeling until now, until the pandemic, because I was seeing that look, like all of us, I was riveted to the Fauci reports. I was riveted at the time to what all the anchors were saying on the different news outlets and all the experts that were coming out, and the denial from that White House that this wasn't so bad.
这就像是一场短暂的流感疫情。我真的认为，在否认与政治和科学之间的战斗之间，我们没有朝着一个好的方向发展，这对我们许多人来说不会有好结果。这让我开始思考，你知道的，去讲一个一直萦绕在我心头的故事，杰森，这个故事伴了我一生。我一直都在想这个。我想着总有一天我得把这个故事讲出来。
It was just like a passing flu epidemic. And I really thought that between the denial and between the battle between politics and science, that we were not heading in a good direction, and that this was not going to end well for many of us. And that just got me thinking about, you know, telling a story that has been on my mind, you know, Jason has been on my mind all my life. I've thought about this. And I thought about someday I got to tell the story.
我会讲一些片段，你知道的，和朋友在一起时，你们总是在谈论你们的童年，对吧？你们坐在一起闲聊长大的经历是怎样的。我经常会讲到一些出现在《造梦之家》里的更具开创性的事件。我的很多朋友都对我说：“你为什么不把这个故事拍成电影呢？那会是一部相当不错的电影。”我妈妈甚至还说：“史蒂芬，苏珊·莱西的HBO纪录片多年前上映时，你什么时候把这个故事拍出来？”
And I would tell episodes, you know, with your friends, you're always talking about your childhood, right? You're sitting around spoozing about what it was like to grow up. And I would often tell some of these more seminal events that appear in The Fablemen's. And I had a lot of friends of mine saying, why don't you tell that story on film someday? That'd be a pretty good movie. And my mom even said, Steve, when are you going to tell the story when the HBO, Susan Lacey HBO documentary came out a number of years ago?
太棒了。我妈妈看了之后打电话给我说：“好了，现在你必须把它拍成电影。那必须是一部电影。”对，所以，然后，然后凯特一直非常支持，托尼是那个真正——托尼·库什纳是那个在整个《西区故事》拍摄期间一直不依不挠的人。他一直说：“我太喜欢这个了。”然后为了我们的下一个项目，对吧？
Fantastic. My mom saw it and called me up and she said, okay, now you got to make that a movie. That's got to be a movie. Yeah. So, and then, and then Kate was always supportive and Tony was the one that really, Tony Kushner was the one who really wouldn't let it, let it alone all through West Side Story. He kept saying, I love that. And then for our next number, right?
所以托尼真的是那个点燃最猛烈火焰、让我开始认真考虑这件事的人。太酷了。现在我，现在我看到，你将看到你的一个孩子或你的女儿导演一部电影。我刚看到的。你看到关于那个的新闻了？德斯特里。
And so Tony was really the one that let the, the, the hottest fire to get me to think about getting serious about this. That's so cool. And now I, now I read, you're going to get to see one of your kids or your daughter direct a movie. I just read. You read about that? Destry.
对。我为此感到非常兴奋。她，她是因为一部短片而被录用的。她拍了一部精彩的短片，我非常喜欢，执导《疾速追杀》系列的制片人们看到了它，并给了她一部电影。太酷了。真是太棒了。预算也相当可观。
Yeah. I'm so excited about that. She, she was hired based on a short film. She made a wonderful short film, which I adored and the producers behind the John Wick series saw it and gave her a movie. That's cool. That's really great. With a respectable budget too.
对，所以这对全家人来说都很令人兴奋。她以前是个片场常客吗？她一直在潜移默化地跟你学吗？她确实是，但你知道的，在她生命的大部分时间里，她都热爱马术艺术。对。她是个出色的场地障碍赛骑手，从三岁起她就一直有马。
Yeah. So it's exciting for the whole family. Was she a bit of a set rat? Has she been shadowing you for a long time? She has been, but you know, for most of her life, she was in love with the equestrian arts. Yeah. She was a fantastic hundred jumper and she had horses ever since she was three years
我们都以为她会，你知道的，为了青年奥运会而努力，她会像布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的女儿杰西·斯普林斯汀那样，真的把这当成一生职业。然后发生的事情是——教练们都告诉我们，他们说：“总会有一个时刻，她会发现男孩的魅力，或者她会发现女孩的魅力。”但在任何一种情况下，当她有了这种发现时，那就是转折点。他们要么继续骑马，要么就停下来。
old. And we all thought that she was going, you know, for the junior Olympics that she was going to like Jesse Springsteen, Bruce's daughter, she was really going to make this a career. And, and then what happens is, and the trainers all told us, they said, well, there's going to be a point where she discovers boys or she discovers girls. But in either case, when she makes that discovery, that's the, that's the turning point. They either continue writing or they stop writing.
而德斯特里不再骑马了，但是，她一直热爱电影，她总是来片场，在《西区故事》的道具部门工作了三四个月，我们当时在拍那部电影。所以她每天都在片场，这只是她一直感兴趣的事情。德斯特里做得很好的另一件事是，她是一位出色的剧照摄影师，她的构图以及对黑白影像的运用都非常出色。
And Desterie stopped writing, but, but she always loved movies and she'd always come to the set and she worked in the property department of West Side Story for three and a half, four months. We shot that movie. So she was on set every day and this was just something that she was always interested in doing. And the other thing that Desterie did so well is she's a great stills photographer and her compositions and her use of black and white.
所以我认为她可能是唯一一个某种程度上沿着我的导演足迹走下去的孩子，尽管我所有的孩子都在某种程度上从事艺术工作。太棒了。我喜欢这个。太酷了。现在是赞助商广告时间。感谢 Rocket Money 对我们的支持。听众朋友们，你知道你的订阅服务实际花费是多少吗？
So I thought she might be the only kid that follows sort of in my directing footsteps, although all my kids are in one fashion or another in the arts. That's great. I love that. That's cool. And now a word from her sponsor. Thank you, Rocket Money, for your support. Listener, do you know how much your subscriptions really cost?
大多数美国人认为他们每月在订阅上花大约80美元，而实际总额接近200多美元。没错。你可能每个月都在那些你甚至都不知道的订阅上浪费几百美元。有一款我们非常兴奋的应用程序可以帮你处理所有这些问题。它就是我刚才提到的 Rocket Money。它们以前叫 True Bill，但 Rocket Money 听起来好记多了，对吧？
Most Americans think they spend about 80 bucks a month on subscriptions when the actual total is closer to $200 plus. That's right. You could be wasting hundreds of dollars each month on subscriptions. You don't even know about. There is this app we're very excited about that takes care of all of that for you. And it's called, I said it earlier, Rocket Money. They're formally known as True Bill, but Rocket Money is just so much more fun to say, right?
这款应用程序将你所有的订阅集中在一个地方，然后帮你取消任何你不再需要的订阅。Rocket Money 甚至能找到那些你甚至不知道自己在付费的订阅。你甚至可能会发现自己为某个订阅被重复扣费了。它能处理的事情太多了。要取消订阅，你只需要按一下取消键。剩下的就交给 Rocket Money 来处理吧。现在就用 Rocket Money 摆脱所有无用的订阅吧。
This app shows you all your subscriptions in one place and then it cancels for you whatever you don't still want. Rocket Money can even find subscriptions you didn't even know you were paying for. You may even find out that you were double charged for a subscription. It takes care of so much. To cancel a subscription, all you have to do is press cancel. And Rocket Money is going to take care of the rest. Let's get rid of all the useless subscriptions with Rocket Money right now.
让我们访问 rocketmoney.com 斜杠 smartlist。说真的，它每年能帮你省下几百美元。网址是 rocketmoney.com 斜杠 smartlist。现在就去 rocketmoney.com 斜杠 smartlist 取消所有不必要的订阅。我不会再说第二遍了。SmartLess 受到 Zip Recruiter 的支持。嘿，伙计们，每个人都会做新年愿望清单，对吧？我不做什么新年愿望清单。
Let's go to rocketmoney.com slash smartlist. Seriously, it could save you hundreds of dollars per year. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartlist. All your unnecessary subscriptions right now at rocketmoney.com slash smartlist. I'm not going to say it again. Smartlist is supported by Zip Recruiter. Hey guys, everybody does a New Year's resolution, right? I don't do a New Year's resolution.
我为一整年做愿望清单。我随时都在做愿望清单。我每天都有一个。我每两个月都有一个。我现在正处于一个愿望清单中。不管怎样，我要找一个私人教练，我要坚持锻炼。这就是我今年的愿望清单。很难找到在擅长的领域如此优秀的人，对吧？
I do a resolution for the whole year. I do a resolution all the time. I do one every day. I do one every other month. I'm on a resolution now. Anyway, I am getting a personal trainer and I'm going to stick to a workout. And it's going to be my resolution for the year. It's hard to find people who are so good at what they do, isn't it?
这就好像如果你在招聘，你该如何为团队中的所有不同角色找到最优秀的人才呢？很简单，用 Zip Recruiter。现在你可以在 ziprecruiter.com 斜杠 smartlist 上免费试用。Zip Recruiter 利用其强大的匹配技术为你寻找合适的工作候选人。看到一个非常适合你工作的候选人了吗？Zip Recruiter 让向他们发送个人邀请变得轻而易举，这样他们更有可能申请。
It's like if you're hiring, how can you find the best people for all the different roles on your team? Easy Zip Recruiter. And right now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. Zip Recruiter uses its powerful matching technology to find the right candidates for your job. See a candidate who'd be perfect for your job? Zip Recruiter makes it easy to send them a personal invite so they're more likely to
让 Zip Recruiter 帮你的所有职位找到最优秀的人才。在 Zip Recruiter 上发布招聘信息的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天内就能找到优质候选人。亲自去看看吧。访问这个专属网址免费试用 Zip Recruiter：ziprecruiter.com 斜杠 smartlist。网址是 ziprecruiter.com 斜杠 S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S。Zip Recruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。
apply. Let Zip Recruiter help you find the best people for all your roles. Four out of five employers who post on Zip Recruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zip Recruiter for free ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. And that's ziprecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S Zip Recruiter, smartest way to hire.
好了，回到节目中。我想化身狂热粉丝，问你关于你一生中拍过的每一部电影的问题。好的，化身狂热粉丝吧。尽情地问吧。嗯，肖恩，顺便说一句，在你这么做之前，我想说，史蒂芬，你知道的，我们有幸在做这个播客的过程中，与那些做过真正成为我们文化一部分的事情的人进行交谈，
All right, back to the show. I want to fan out and ask you about every single movie you've ever made in your entire life. Okay, fan out. Fan away there. Well, Sean, by the way, before you do that, I was going to say, Stephen, you know, it's so we've had the honor when, you know, through the course of doing this podcast of talking to people who've done things that have, you know, that are really part of our culture
或者说，文化织锦戏剧就编织在其中。当然你正处于这份名单的最顶端。多年来，你的电影就像是，你知道的，当人们回首往事时，这些都是试金石般的电影。这些电影代表了人们生命中的不同时代。对你来说，它们也有着某种象征意义，但每个人都有自己的诠释，因为他们在不同的年龄观看，经历着不同的事情。我可以回想并梳理你所有的电影。
or, you know, cultural fabric theater just woven right in there. And certainly you're right at the top of that list. Your films for many, many years have been like, you know, when people look back on their lives, these are touchstone films. These are films that represent different eras in people's lives. And for you, they have a representation too, but everybody has their own interpretation because they watch it at whatever age and whatever they were going through. And I can go back and think through all your films.
我在电影院看《大白鲨》时还是个小孩子。去看的时候年纪实在太小了，但我还是和死党杰弗里的生日派对一起去了，因为他妈妈有点神经质，允许我们在年纪太小的时候去看。我记得——这是一个真实的故事，我从没说过——我当时故意笑，因为我太害怕了，我笑是为了欺骗自己，让自己不要害怕。我至今还保留着那段记忆。
I saw Jaws in the theater. I was a little kid. I was way too young to see it in the theater, but I did for my buddy, Jeffrey's birthday party because his mom was a little bit of a wing nut and she let us go and see it when we were too young. And I remember, this is a true story, I've never said, I laughed on purpose because I was so scared that I laughed in order to fool myself to not be scared. And I still have that memory.
那是你拍的一部电影，千千万万像我一样、像我们一样的人，对所有这些电影都有着不同的记忆。你曾经有过吗？每当我看到《大白鲨》时，我都会因为害怕而笑。这是你会经常思考的事情吗？我是说，你知道这种连接，与这个星球上的人们建立的这种连接，其中是否有一种，我不想让你难堪，但其中是否有某种分量？是的。
And that is a movie that you made and that is, and so many people, millions and millions of people like me, like us have different memories from all those films. Do you ever? I laugh because I'm so scared whenever I see Jason. Is it something that you ever think about? I mean, is there a, I don't want to put you on the spot, but is there a weight to that at all knowing that connection that you've had with the people of this planet? Yeah.
嗯，你知道，我只能回过头来，通过这种方式来回馈，那就是当我大约16岁时，在亚利桑那州菲尼克斯的卡普里剧院，坐在那些摇摆座椅上，周围每个人都在低吸烟区抽烟，你还记得吗，第一次看《阿拉伯的劳伦斯》的时候。我从不抽烟，所以对我来说，那感觉就像是在沙漠场景中，我被人们的香烟烟雾呛得喘不过气来，但那对我来说具有开创性意义。那是我的试金石，起初它可能并没有让我想要成为一名导演，因为我认为我永远、永远也无法达到我刚刚经历的那种高度。
Well, you know, I can only turn around and sort of pay it forward by paying it back by saying when I saw Laurence of Arabia for the first time, when I was like 16 years old, in Phoenix, Arizona at the Capri theater with those rocking seats, with everybody smoking around you in the low smoking section, you recall. And I never smoked, so for me, that was kind of like desert scenes and I'm choking on people's cigarette smoke, but that was seminal for me. And that was the touchstone for me that really, at first, maybe not want to be a director because I thought I'll never, ever be able to get anywhere near what I've just experienced.
但后来我每隔几周就去看一次那部电影，我回去看了一遍又一遍，哇，你知道的，所以当人们走到我面前对我说——首先走到我面前对我说，我跟某人聊天，他们说：“你知道吗，我七岁时看了《E.T.》。”而对我说这话的那个人看起来和我年纪差不多，我在想，好吧，这让我觉得自己有多大年龄了？当然。说到这个，顺便说到我第一次见你的那次，那是很多很多年前，我走到你面前跟你讲了这个故事，那就是当我11岁时看了《E.T.》，我哥哥，我哥哥凯文带我去看了这部电影作为我的生日礼物，看完电影后——当然电影院里的每个人都在哭——我说：“我愿意付出一切去成为他。”我哥哥说：“埃利奥特，我知道，能有 E.T. 这样的朋友，不是很酷吗？”我说：“不，我愿意付出一切去成为亨利·托马斯，就像在11岁时，我就知道我想成为他，我想得到那个角色。”我知道我想成为一部如此伟大的电影里的演员，那就是我顿悟的时刻。
But then I kept seeing the movie every couple of weeks, I went back and saw it and again, and wow, you know, so when people come up to me and they say, well, the first thing to come up to me and they say, I'm talking to someone and they say, you know, I saw E.T. when I was seven years old and the person telling me that looks like they're my age and I'm going, well, how long does that make me feel? Of course. Speaking of though, speaking of the first time I ever met you, years and years ago, and I came up to you and I told you this story, which was when I was, I saw E.T. when I was
太棒了。我可以，我可以问吗？杰森，你为《E.T.》试镜了多少次回调？我连试读的机会都没有。我可以快速问一个关于制作流程的死宅问题吗？你激励了我们这么多立志成为电影人的同行，做了很多很多事情，其中最主要的就是镜头设计。所以我有一个关于这个的问题。
11 years old, my brother took me, my brother, Kevin took me for my birthday and I said, after the movie is over and of course everybody was crying in the theater, I said, I'd give anything to be him and my brother said, Elliot, I know to have a friend like E.T. wouldn't that be so cool? I go, no, I'd give anything to be Henry Thomas, like at 11 years old, I knew that I wanted to be, I wanted that part. I knew that I wanted to be an actor in a film that that was that great and that's when I kind of knew.
很显然，这些镜头的设计有时非常具体，以增强场景试图表达的含义。因此，整个场景构思的视觉呈现显然是由你在演员进入片场之前、在你发现每个人将如何走位和交谈之前设计好的。你能对一个年轻的电影人说些什么：当他们做好了很棒的镜头设计，结果你一到片场，演员却说：“嗯，不，我觉得我不会坐在这把椅子上。我觉得我会站在这边靠着这堵墙。”这直接毁了你的镜头设计，因此可能无法对场景试图表达的含义提供相同的视觉支持。你会对那个演员说什么？我的意思是，我想你现在不会遇到这种自负的演员的问题了。但是你如何处理那种创造性的合作与谈判呢？他们立刻就被解雇了。
That's fantastic. Can I, can I do it? Jason, how many callbacks did you have for E.T.? I couldn't get a reading. Can I dork out on a process question real quick? So you have inspired so many of our, of us aspiring filmmakers in many, many things, not the least of which is shot design. And so I have a question about that.
我在60年代末和70年代初刚涉足电视圈时就遇到过这种事。当我遇到这位演员时，他一直想当导演。他比我大得多，从来没有机会当导演，他主演了我当时正在制作的这部电视电影，他对我的任何要求都不理不睬。他根本不听我的任何话。最后，在最后一个镜头，最后一个镜头碰巧是一个会议室，他本该发表一段演讲，并且本该在场景结束时从一扇门走出去。那其实不是一扇门。
You're clearly, these things, these shots are designed sometimes so specifically to augment what the scene is trying to say. So that whole sort of visual presentation on the idea of the scene that that's obviously been designed by you before actors get on set and before you have discovered where everyone's going to walk and talk. What can you say to a young filmmaker when they've got some great shot design and you get on the set and the actor says, well, no, I don't think I would sit in that chair. I think I'd be standing over here against this wall, which destroys your shot design
那是一个微小的空间，可能只有三英尺深。他本要打开门，走进去并关上门，然后我本该喊“卡”。那时候，我已经忍无可忍了，而他是个专业演员。所以当我喊“动作”时，他演完了那个场景，然后退场了。他走进了那个小衣柜，关上了门。我转向其他演员坐着的桌子，说道：“好了，开始即兴发挥吧。”我让他们继续说话并即兴发挥了八分钟，而他一直站在衣柜里
and therefore might not have the same visual kind of support for what the scene's trying to say. What do you say to that actor? I mean, I imagine you don't have that problem nowadays with an uppity actor. But how do you, how do you manage that sort of that creative collaboration and negotiation? They're fired immediately. That happened to me in television when I was first joining in TV in the late sixties and early seventies.
因此可能无法为场景想要表达的内容提供相同的视觉支持。你对这样的演员说什么？我的意思是，我想你现在不会遇到这种傲慢演员的问题了。但是你如何，你如何处理那种创造性的合作和谈判？他们立刻被解雇了。我在六十年代末和七十年代初刚进入电视界时就遇到过这种情况。
And when I met this actor, he had wanted to be a director. He was much older than me and he never had a chance to direct and he was starring in this TV movie I was making and he wouldn't do anything I told him at all. And he wouldn't do a single thing I told him. And I finally, on the last shot, the last shot happened to be a conference room and he was supposed to give a speech and he was supposed to exit at the end of the scene out a door. It wasn't really a door.
当我遇到这位演员时，他本来想当导演。他比我大得多，一直没有机会当导演，他在我制作的一部电视电影里主演，但他对我的话根本置之不理。我让他做的任何事情他都不做。最后，在最后一个镜头时，这个镜头刚好是一个会议室，他本该发表一段演讲，并且在场景结束时从一扇门走出去。那其实并不是一扇真正的门。
It was a teeny little space. It was maybe only three feet deep. And he was going to open the door, go in and close it and I was supposed to say cut. And by that time, I was at the end of my rope and he was a professional. And so when I said action, he played the scene and then he'd made his exit. He went into that little closet and closed the door. And I turned to the table of other actors and I said, okay, start improvising. And I made them talk and improvise for eight minutes while he stood in the closet for eight
那是一个极小的空间，大概只有三英尺深。他要打开门，走进去关上，而我应该喊“停”。到那时，我已经忍无可忍了，但他是个专业演员。所以当我喊“开始”时，他演完了那场戏，然后退场。他走进那个小橱柜并关上了门。我转向另一桌演员，说，好吧，开始即兴表演。我让他们边聊边即兴发挥了八分钟，而他就站在那个衣柜里待了八分钟
minutes. And then when I finally said cut the door open, I was expecting to get punched out in front of the whole crew and he walked right by me, didn't look at me and he apparently left the soundstage, got in his car and went home and that was the plan to solve it. That's a win. I was going to ask you too, I think that you're known as one of the great stages of directors. Your staging is beyond, I don't think anybody's ever staged the way you do. Is that something that you learned or is that something that you just innately knew?
分钟。最后当我终于说切开这扇门时，我以为我会在全体剧组人员面前挨揍，而他从我身边走过，甚至看都没看我一眼，他显然离开了摄影棚，上了车回家了，这就是解决问题的计划。这真是一场胜利。我正想问你，我认为你是伟大的场面调度导演之一。你的场面调度超越了一切，我觉得没有任何人的场面调度能达到你的水平。这是你学来的，还是你天生就知道的？
Like it's just, because I think that it's kind of a lot that the art of that is just, I don't think it's talked about enough in filmmaking. Thank you. Especially. Thank you very much for that. Staging to me is one of the most important things I can contribute to telling a story again because I think that the shots essentially are a way to illuminate what the writer has already put down on paper and what the actors have already interpreted to be their new selves
就像是，因为我觉得这里面有很多艺术成分，只是我觉得电影界对这个讨论得还不够。谢谢你。尤其是。非常感谢你这么说。对我来说，场面调度是我为讲好一个故事所能贡献的最重要的东西之一，因为我认为镜头本质上是一种方式，用来阐明编剧已经落实在纸上的东西，以及演员们已经诠释出的他们的新自我
as we all work as a company. And so my part of that collaboration is to illuminate and even to strengthen some of the moments through shot study or through blocking. And I just know growing up that I was always amazed at moving cameras, especially Louis Milestone, the moving cameras of All Quiet on the Western Front or his Korean war drama Pork Chop Hill, those amazing shots where the camera just climbs a hill with Gregory Peck and Woody Strode and Robert Blake and they're climbing this hill. And the first thing I thought about was that is the coolest shot.
因为我们大家作为一个团队在工作。因此，我在这场合作中的部分工作是通过镜头研究或调度来阐明甚至强化一些时刻。我只知道在成长过程中，我总是对运动镜头感到惊叹，尤其是刘易斯·迈尔斯通，《西线无战事》中运动的镜头，或者他的朝鲜战争剧情片《猪排山》，那些令人惊叹的镜头，摄影机只是和格里高利·派克、伍迪·斯特罗德、罗伯特·布莱克一起爬上一座山，他们正在爬这座山。我脑子里想的第一件事就是，这是最酷的镜头。
And the second thing I thought was how many people would take the push of dolly up a 30 degree incline. So I was always sort of behind the scenes as I was admiring what was happening in front of me. And I'm just in William Wilder's staging and blocking and certainly Billy Wilder staging and blocking. I just, they're just directors that I learned so much from. Sorry, Sean, I just want to say as a follow up to that then, because there is a very,
而我想到的第二件事是，有多少人会把推车推上30度的斜坡。所以我一边欣赏着眼前发生的一切，一边总是处于幕后。威廉·怀尔德的场面调度和分切，当然还有比利·怀尔德的场面调度和分切。我只是，他们是让我学到这么多的导演。对不起，肖恩，我只是想作为对此的后续说一下，因为有一个非常，
you know, I noticed, especially now with filmmakers, not to get again to inside baseball, but we've become increasingly reliant on cutting and on close ups, et cetera, et cetera. And I remember I watch Close Encounters probably once every year, maybe every year and a half. I can't stop watching that film. For whatever reason, certain films speak to you and it's always scratched an itch for me. And there's a scene where Richard Dreyfus is finally losing it and he's at home and the camera is almost like it's on the threshold of this door between the two rooms, you know,
你知道，我注意到，特别是现在电影制作人，不是又要谈内行话了，但我们越来越依赖剪辑和特写等等。我记得我大概每年看一次《第三类接触》，也许一年半一次。我停不下来看那部电影。不管出于什么原因，某些电影会触动你，它总是能挠到我的痒处。有一个场景，理查德·德莱弗斯终于情绪失控了，他在家里，摄影机几乎就像是在两个房间之间的这扇门的门槛上，你知道的，
between the living room and the sort of the kitchen and you never cut and it's not gratuitous. It's not like, oh, this is one take and you're looking for applause because you're telling the scene and you're able to capture that frenzy of that moment of this family that's falling apart. And everybody's talking over each other, but you can still understand it. The camera moves with everybody and I just thought it's such an unheralded moment. And yet once you start to understand what the filmmaking process, you're like, this is a great way to tell this part of the story in a way that people don't realize.
在客厅和厨房之间，你从不剪辑，而且这并不突兀。这不像是，哦，这是个一镜到底，你在等着掌声，因为你在讲述这个场景，你能够捕捉到这个正在崩溃的家庭那个疯狂的时刻。每个人都在抢着说话，但你仍然能听懂。摄影机跟着每个人移动，我只是觉得这是一个如此被埋没的时刻。然而，一旦你开始了解电影制作的过程，你就会觉得，这是以一种人们意识不到的方式讲述故事这一部分的好方法。
And thank you. And I think that that particular moment is something that did not come out of storyboarding or was not on a shot list. Part of what inspires me to figure out how to frame or how to travel in terms of blocking the actors is, you know, getting everybody on stage and letting them do what comes naturally to them. If they get to know their characters well enough, they're going to know whether they should be sitting, standing, kneeling or turning.
谢谢你。我认为那个特定的时刻并非来自故事板，也不是分镜头脚本的一部分。启发我如何构图或如何根据演员调度来运镜的部分原因是，你知道，把每个人叫到舞台上，让他们做对他们来说最自然的事。如果他们足够了解自己的角色，他们就会知道自己应该是坐着、站着、跪着还是转身。
And there's an intuitive trust I have in the intuitive ability of an actor, a really fine actor, and even a real fine intuitive actor that might just be starting out in movies or television, that they bring things to the table. And I'll just let them block themselves, meaning just move around. And usually in terms of safety, when I say, let's just run the lines, the actors pretty much stand to the liver. They stand looking at each other and they have their scripts open if they're still on book. And they'll just start doing the dialogue.
我对演员的直觉能力有一种直觉上的信任，一个非常优秀的演员，甚至是一个可能刚刚开始涉足电影或电视的非常优秀的直觉型演员，他们会带来很多东西。我会让他们自己调度，意思就是随便走动。通常为了安全起见，当我问，我们来走一下台词吧，演员们基本上会站着说台词。他们站着看着对方，如果他们还没背熟台词，就拿着剧本。然后他们就开始念台词。
And sometimes actors will start just traveling. They'll just start wandering around and it'll give me an idea. And I won't even say, why did you walk to the refrigerator and open it? I won't even ask that. I'll say, oh, that's great. It's like theater. It's just to be honest. It's like theater.
有时演员会开始走动。他们会开始四处闲逛，这会给我灵感。我甚至不会问，你为什么走到冰箱前打开它？我甚至不会问这个。我会说，哦，太棒了。这就像戏剧。说实话。这就像戏剧。
And Mike Nichols is one of my favorite directors and so is Elia Kazan. And you look at their blocking. Look at Nichols blocking in Carnal Knowledge and in The Graduate. And also especially, maybe the best blocking Nichols ever did was his first movie, Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf. And then you look at the blocking that Kazan did with Street Cart Name Desire. And you wonder, you got to wonder, was that blocking, those brilliant blocking choices not made in collaboration with the actors who put ideas in Kazan and Nichols head?
迈克·尼科尔斯是我最喜欢的导演之一，埃里亚·卡赞也是。看看他们的调度。看看尼科尔斯在《肉体之味》和《毕业生》中的调度。而且尤其是，尼科尔斯做过的最好的调度也许是他的第一部电影，谁害怕弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫？然后你看看卡赞在《欲望号街车》中的调度。你会想，你不得不怀疑，那个调度，那些精彩的调度选择，难道不是与那些把想法放进卡赞和尼科尔斯脑子里的演员合作完成的吗？
And that's the kind of collaboration that happens in theater, as you know, from your experience on stage. That's so cool. Yeah, I love that. So, you know, like I said, I could go through every single movie you ever made. It's just the effect that you and your film has had on me and like Will said, billions of people is just unbelievable. But I want to talk about, I could ask you a thousand questions about JAWS, but you're
这就是戏剧中发生的这种合作，正如你从舞台经验中所知道的那样。太酷了。是的，我喜欢这样。所以，你知道，就像我说的，我可以看完你拍过的每一部电影。只是你和你的电影对我和像威尔所说的数十亿人产生的影响真是令人难以置信。但我想谈谈，我可以问你关于《大白鲨》的一千个问题，但你
probably so sick of talking about that. By the way, is it true that the word blockbuster came from JAWS? I don't know. I don't know where the word blockbuster came from. It's true. It's true. Yes. Yes, sure.
可能已经厌倦了谈论这个。顺便问一下，“大片”（blockbuster）这个词真的是从《大白鲨》来的吗？我不知道。我不知道“大片”这个词是从哪来的。这是真的。这是真的。是的。没错。当然。
Because the line was around the block. So, but Indiana Jones. But it was also around the block for The Greatest Show on Earth by C.B. DeMille and also around the block for Gone With the Wind. Everybody thinks that JAWS was the first blockbuster and JAWS was by far not the first blockbuster. Yeah, but I know somebody coined that phrase, I think, for that movie, but I don't know. Take it, Steven. Take it.
因为队伍排到了街区外。所以，但是《夺宝奇兵》。但塞西尔·B·德米尔的《地球上最伟大的表演》和《乱世佳人》排的队伍也绕过街区。每个人都以为《大白鲨》是第一部大片，《大白鲨》远远不是第一部大片。是的，但我知道有人为那部电影创造了这个词，我想，但我不知道。你来吧，史蒂文。你来吧。
I'll take it. Thank you. By the way, before I get into those questions. And then George took it from me a couple years later. For what? For what? We used to take from each other in the old days. Well, speaking of George, how did you meet George and then, and I want to go back to
我来。谢谢。顺便说一句，在我回答那些问题之前。几年后乔治把它从我这拿走了。为了什么？为了什么？在过去的日子里，我们过去常常从彼此那里拿走东西。好吧，说到乔治，你是怎么认识乔治的，然后，我想回到
all those others, but how did you meet George and two parts about Indiana Jones? How did you meet George? And then also casting Harrison Ford on the heels of Star Wars and Empire Strikes Back. Aren't there like a concern about the audience buying him as anything other than Han Solo? Like how did you, how did that come about? Well, in quick succession, I met George through a brighter friend of my, Matthew Robbins, and he suggested I go to, I was at Long Beach State College and he said there's a contest between UCLA film students and USC film students happening at Royce Hall at UCLA.
所有那些其他人，但你是怎么认识乔治的，关于《夺宝奇兵》有两个部分？你是怎么认识乔治的？还有在《星球大战》和《帝国反击战》之后选定哈里森·福特。难道没有观众会把他当成韩·索罗以外的任何人来看的担忧吗？就像你是怎么，这是怎么发生的呢？好吧，紧接着，我通过我的一个好朋友马修·罗宾斯认识了乔治，他建议我去，当时我在长滩州立学院，他说加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）电影系学生和加州大学南加州分校（USC）电影系学生之间在UCLA的罗伊斯音乐厅有一场比赛。
And so I went to the, to the contest, to the competition and THX1138 played and won everything. Of course. Just won all the awards. Loved it. And so I went backstage and I had met Francis Coppola a couple of times in Francis and Matthew Robbins introduced me to George. We met backstage when he had just won, he had just beat UCLA, USC beat UCLA, not just a basketball and football, but in movies.
所以我去了比赛，去了那场竞赛，THX1138上映并赢得了所有奖项。当然。简直赢得了所有奖项。我很喜欢。所以我去了后台，我见过弗朗西斯·科波拉几次，弗朗西斯和马修·罗宾斯把我介绍给了乔治。我们在后台见面，当时他刚刚赢了，他刚刚击败了UCLA，USC击败了UCLA，不仅仅是在篮球和足球上，而是在电影上。
And that was a good deal for them and for me to beat George for the first time. And then, you know, George and I became fast friends and when Star Wars was coming out, I've told the story before, but when Star Wars was about to come out, George liked to run to Hawaii and hide from bad news. He was very much like me. If we're going to get bad news, let's get bad news in Hawaii, let's not get bad news in Encino. Yeah.
这对他们和我来说都是一件好事，第一次击败乔治。然后，你知道，乔治和我成了至交好友，当《星球大战》即将上映时，我以前说过这个故事，但当《星球大战》即将上映时，乔治喜欢逃到夏威夷去躲避坏消息。他很像我。如果我们听到坏消息，让我们在夏威夷听到坏消息，不要在恩西诺听到坏消息。是的。
It's a good idea. Yeah. Nothing wrong with Encino, by the way, but better to have bad news in Hawaii. And so we went to Hawaii, George inaugurated this thing about building lucky sandcastles and you build it close to the high tide mark. And then if the sandcastle the next morning is no longer there, the ocean wiped it out, your film will be a flop. And if the castle still is there, the film is going to be a hit.
这是个好主意。是的。恩西诺没什么不对的，顺便说一句，但在夏威夷听到坏消息更好。所以我们去了夏威夷，乔治发起了一件关于建造幸运沙堡的事情，你把它建在靠近高潮线的地方。然后，如果第二天早上沙堡不在了，被海洋冲走了，你的电影就会惨败。如果城堡还在，电影就会大获成功。
So we built the sandcastle. Come on. Just as the sun was going down, the next morning we ran down to the beach and it was intact. And about, I don't know, a couple hours later, he found out on a telephone call that every single 10 30 AM show of Star Wars was sold out across the entire nation. Wow. Wow. So this is before tracking.
所以我们建了沙堡。拜托。就在太阳下山的时候，第二天早上我们跑到海滩上，它完好无损。大约，我不知道，几个小时后，他通过一个电话发现，全国各地所有上午10点30分的《星球大战》场次都卖光了。哇。哇。所以这是在票房追踪系统出现之前。
Yeah. This is before tracking. And so that's when George in his euphoria asked me what I wanted to do next. And I said, I want to do a James Bond film, but Cubby Broccoli won't hire me. I've asked him twice. And right. Even after Jaws, he wouldn't hire me. Wow.
是的。这是在票房追踪系统出现之前。所以就在那时，乔治在狂喜中问我接下来想做什么。我说，我想拍一部詹姆斯·邦德电影，但卡比·布洛克利不雇佣我。我问过他两次。而且对。即使在《大白鲨》之后，他也不雇佣我。哇。
And George says, well, I got that beat. I got something called Raiders of the Lost Ark. You should do that instead. And that's how I got involved in that. And the Harrison story is very simple. George asked me to come up and look at a cut of Empire Strikes Back, and we were still casting for Indy. And I just said to him, what about that guy for Indiana Jones?
乔治说，好吧，我比那个更厉害。我有个叫《夺宝奇兵》的项目。你该拍那个。这就是我如何参与其中的。哈里森的故事很简单。乔治让我去看看《帝国反击战》的剪辑版，我们当时还在为印第选角。我只是对他说，印第安纳·琼斯选那个家伙怎么样？
That guy. And George said, well, that's Han Solo. And I said, yeah, but he's an actor. He can play more than Han Solo. John Wayne was in 57 Westerns, playing different characters as John Wayne. And George started taking it seriously. So we sent the script to Harrison and he loved it and said, yes. I love that.
那个家伙。乔治说，嗯，那是韩·索罗。我说，对，但他是个演员。他能演的不止韩·索罗。约翰·韦恩演过57部西部片，以约翰·韦恩的身份扮演不同的角色。乔治开始认真对待了。所以我们把剧本寄给哈里森，他很喜欢并答应了。我喜欢这样。
You mentioned that you went and you saw a cut of Empire Strikes Back. That's something that I just think so cool, that you guys, your peers at a very, very high level, look at each other's work at an early stage and give notes and help one another out. Is that still very, very frequent for you? And I imagine that group changes a little bit every once in a while. It was part of a wave where all of us were interactive with each other for years. It doesn't happen so much anymore.
你提到你去看过《帝国反击战》的剪辑版。我觉得这太酷了，你们这些处于极高水平的同龄人，会在早期阶段看彼此的作品并给出意见，互相帮助。这种事对你来说现在还非常非常频繁吗？而且我能想象这个群体每隔一段时间就会稍微变一下。这是我们所有人多年来互相交流的一股浪潮的一部分。现在不经常这样了。
But oh my God, in the 70s and 80s, we couldn't wait to take our movies and we couldn't wait for the royal drumming because it was not always, our rough cuts were not always greeted with support. It was usually, this doesn't work. You got to fix it. You got to throw that out. You got to reshoot this. You got to reshoot that.
但天哪，在70和80年代，我们迫不及待地拿着我们的电影，我们迫不及待地等待当头棒喝，因为这并不总是，我们的粗剪版并不总是受到支持。通常是，这行不通。你得修改。你得把这个扔掉。你得重拍这个。你得重拍那个。
And it would get kind of violent sometimes. I remember when George showed Star Wars to all of us. He showed Star Wars for the first time to about 40 of us. And I would not say it was the best rough cut screening anybody had ever seen. And I'm not saying that I was prescient or anything, but I was the only person in the room that said, this is great. It's going to make a ton of money. And we went to a Chinese restaurant and everybody just started coming down on the film.
有时甚至会变得有点激烈。我记得当乔治向我们所有人展示《星球大战》时。他第一次向我们大约40个人展示《星球大战》。我不会说这是任何人见过最好的粗剪版试映。我不是说我有先见之明什么的，但我是房间里唯一一个说，这太棒了。这会赚一大笔钱的人。我们去了一家中餐馆，大家开始对这部电影大加批判。
It didn't make sense. Who are these guys? Who are the guys that looked like Nazis, but they're all in white, all this is stormtroopers. And there were no special effects. You have to understand it was all blue screen. It was like bang, bang. There was nothing. And every time there was Star Wars, when Star Wars were happening, George cut to black
这说不通。这些人是谁？这些看起来像纳粹但都穿着白色衣服的人是谁，所有这些都是帝国冲锋队。而且没有特效。你必须明白，这全是蓝幕。就像砰，砰。什么都没有。而且每次有《星球大战》的镜头时，当《星球大战》发生时，乔治切到了
and white gun camera footage of P-51s and Stuka's dive bombing things. So you went from color with blue screen to black and white stock footage from World War 2. And you're like, this is good luck, George. I thought it was great. I actually, the only people that flipped out for it was me and the head of the studio, Alamed Vlad Jr., who had financed the film at Fox. And Ladi and I, we thought it was going to be great.
P-51和斯图卡俯冲轰炸物体的黑白枪击镜头。所以你从带有蓝幕的彩色画面转换到了二战的黑白库存镜头。你会觉得，祝你好运，乔治。我觉得这很棒。实际上，唯一为此疯狂的人是我和工作室负责人阿拉梅德·弗拉德·朱尼尔（Alan Ladd Jr.），他在福克斯为这部电影提供了资金。拉迪和我，我们觉得这会很棒。
I have a quick question from Scotty here, who's in love with you like I am like anybody else. He says, first of all, he can sing every single word in Mandarin from anything goes from Indiana Jones in the Temple of Doom. For real. He memorized the whole thing in Mandarin. And my wife doesn't remember, I keep asking Kate to sing it for me and she says, I forgot the Mandarin.
我这里有个斯科蒂的小问题，他像我一样崇拜你，就像其他任何人一样。他说，首先，他能用普通话唱出《夺宝奇兵2：魔宫传奇》中《无论如何》里的每一个字。真的。他用普通话背下了整首。我妻子不记得了，我一直让凯特唱给我听，她说，我忘了普通话了。
Yeah. No, he'll remind you. And if by, this is a real question. If by some miracle this is from Scotty, you happen to be home with Kate watching TV and you're scrolling for something to watch. What is the movie you will always stop and watch even with commercials? Dr. Javago, because it's kind of the film we sort of fell in love with together. Oh, that's nice.
对。不，他会提醒你的。如果，这是一个真实的问题。如果由于某种奇迹，这是来自斯科蒂的，恰巧你和凯特在家看电视，正在搜寻要看的东西。你会总是停下来看、甚至带广告也看的电影是什么？《日瓦戈医生》，因为这是我们一起爱上的电影。哦，真好。
That's cool. Good question. And I ask you about, there's a shot in Empire of the Sun, which thank you for discovering Christian Bale, where I think it's that spot when he runs up on the roof and, you know, I forget what he says about the jet going over to the sky, and I think the camera stops its pan and in the deep, deep distance, there's a parachute coming down in the background. It might be that shot. It might be a different one, but I always thought, my God, to be so easy to make that
太酷了。好问题。我想问你，在《太阳帝国的帝国》中有一个镜头，谢谢你发掘了克里斯蒂安·贝尔，我想那是他跑上屋顶的那个镜头，你知道的，我忘了他对飞过天空的喷气式飞机说了什么，我想摄影机停止了摇镜头，在极远极远的背景里，有一个降落伞正落下来。可能是那个镜头。可能是另一个，但我总是想，天哪，要拍出那个
incredible shot without that parachute, the fact that you, it must be very difficult to drop a World War, what was it, one or a parachute or two parachute and get it in the frame and the composition of that. How difficult was that to do and how ambitious to say, no, that's what we're doing today. And it's going to take, you know, a whole day to do an eighth. That wasn't the script. It was Tom Stoppard's contribution who wrote the script based on the J.G. Ballard book. And Tom just created a kind of dream world for Jim, played by Christian Bale.
不可思议的镜头，如果没有那个降落伞，事实是，你，投放一个二战时期的，那是什么，一个降落伞还是两个降落伞，让它进入画面和构图，一定非常困难。做这件事有多难，而且敢于说“不，我们今天就要这样做，而且这需要，你知道，整整一天来拍八分之一页”是多么雄心勃勃。那不在剧本里。那是汤姆·斯托帕德（Tom Stoppard）的贡献，他根据J.G.巴拉德（J.G. Ballard）的书写了剧本。汤姆只是为吉姆（由克里斯蒂安·贝尔饰演）创造了一个梦幻世界。
And he's been hugged by Dr. Rawlings because he's sort of gone, you know, he's become hysterical, let's say, on the roof. And Dr. Rawlings is trying to calm him down. And when he embraces him, Jim looks up and this parachute's coming down. And it was just something that Tom had put in the script to create a kind of dream state for both the character and for the audience. In order to call into question, is this really happening in reality or is this only happening in Jim's imagination?
他被罗林斯医生拥抱着，因为他在屋顶上有点崩溃了，可以说是歇斯底里了。罗林斯医生正试图让他平静下来。当他拥抱他时，吉姆抬头看到这个降落伞落下来。这只是汤姆写在剧本里，为角色和观众创造一种梦境状态的东西。为了质疑，这究竟是在现实中发生，还是只发生在吉姆的想象中？
Since Jim had an overly active imagination. Yeah, but so difficult probably to... I don't remember if it was difficult or not. I have a feeling that it was one of those things where we had the stuntman on a crane and there was probably even... I'm not really sure. I kind of forgot how we did that. It was a long time ago.
既然吉姆有着过于活跃的想象力。是的，但可能很难……我不记得它是不是很难。我有一种感觉，那是我们在起重机上有一个特技演员的那种情况，甚至可能还有……我真的不确定。我有点忘了我们是怎么做到的了。那是很久以前的事了。
I'll bet you probably had to drop him from a plane and just pan the camera to wherever he's going to drop down frame left or frame right and just kind of pivot with it. Because I don't think you get a crane up that high with those old parachutes. I'm not sure. It might have been actually just, you know, we might have cheated the shot also and lowered the roof or something. But I'm not sure we didn't drop him from a crane because I mean from an airplane because everybody would just been panic stricken hoping his shoot would open.
我敢打赌你可能不得不把他从飞机上扔下来，然后把摄影机摇到他要掉到画面的左边或右边的任何地方，然后顺着它旋转。因为我认为你用那些旧降落伞把起重机升不到那么高。我不确定。实际上可能只是，你知道，我们可能也作弊了镜头，把屋顶降低了或者什么的。但我不能确定我们没有把他从起重机上放下来，我的意思是，从飞机上，因为每个人都会惊慌失措，希望他的降落伞能打开。
All right. That's what I mean. The shot was just amazing anyway. So I think it was early 90s, I can't remember the 92 or 93 or something. One of as many, but one of your most impressive years in your career, both Jurassic Park and Schindler's List came out in the same year. And Jurassic Park was the highest grossing movie ever at that time. And did you have any, like they're so contrasting films obviously was that, that wasn't by design.
好吧。这就是我的意思。无论如何，这个镜头太棒了。所以我想那是90年代初，我不记得是92年还是93年左右。在你职业生涯的众多巅峰中，令人印象最深刻的一年是，《侏罗纪公园》和《辛德勒的名单》在同一年上映。当时《侏罗纪公园》是史上票房最高的电影。你有没有，因为它们显然是如此对比鲜明的电影，那不是刻意设计的吗？
Was that just by accident? Like, did you know when you were making other film they come out the same year and be as successful and when they're both so different? You know, it was interesting because I was, I was very much working only on Jurassic Park in the editing room, I finished my cut, what was left was the mixing and the color correction. But we had the release planned already. And I've been working with Steve Zalion on the Schindler's Lift script for quite a while. And we went to Poland together and we went to, we went to Auschwitz, Steve and I.
那只是个意外吗？就像，当你拍另一部电影时，你知道它们会在同一年上映并取得同样的成功吗，而且当它们如此不同时？你知道，这很有趣，因为我当时，我基本上只在剪辑室里做《侏罗纪公园》，我完成了剪辑，剩下的就是混音和调色。但我们已经计划好上映时间了。我和斯蒂芬·扎利安（Steve Zaillian）为《辛德勒的名单》剧本工作了很长时间。我们一起去了波兰，我们去了，我们去了奥斯威辛，史蒂文和我。
And we went to all the actual locations, went to saw the apartment, Oscar Schindler had taken over from a Jewish family and crack off. We went to the site of the Pwaschow forced labor internment camp. We went to all of these places. And then we both got inspired and Steve had already written to like 115 page draft. And I kept saying to Steve, this has got to be like 170 pages. I mean, let's not, let's just go for it. And when he came back, he had written this extraordinary draft after several months later.
我们去了所有真实的取景地，去看了奥斯卡·辛德勒从克拉科夫的一个犹太家庭接管的公寓。我们去了普瓦舒夫（Płaszów）强制劳工集中营的旧址。我们去了所有这些地方。然后我们都受到了启发，史蒂文已经写了大约115页的初稿。我一直对史蒂文说，这得有170页左右。我的意思是，别这样，我们放手去干吧。当他回来时，几个月后他写出了这部非凡的初稿。
And I read it right in the middle of post-production on Jurassic Park. And something sees me and all I knew was I had to do the movie now. I couldn't wait for another winter. Winter was about to come up. I needed winter for Schindler's List. And I kind of put the production, Schindler production into a fast track in terms of having to cast it and having to location scout. And I kind of, I went to George Lucas and I said, George, I need a huge favor from you.
我在《侏罗纪公园》后期制作的正中间读了它。某种东西击中了我，我所知道的唯一一件事就是我必须现在拍这部电影。我不能等另一个冬天。冬天快到了。《辛德勒的名单》需要冬天。我有点让《辛德勒》的制作进入了快车道，因为必须选角，必须进行外景勘测。我有点，我去找乔治·卢卡斯说，乔治，我需要你帮个大忙。
I've never done this before, but I got to make Schindler's List and don't ask me why. It's just in me, it's in the marrow, in the deepest parts of my, I guess, in that sense. I have to tell the story. It's in my marrow. And I don't want to wait a year. I don't want to let this feeling wane or dissipate. And will you take over the rest of Jurassic Park? So George agreed and George mixed the movie and corrected the color.
我以前从没做过这个，但我得拍《辛德勒的名单》，别问我为什么。它就在我体内，在骨髓里，在我体内最深处，我想，从某种意义上说。我必须讲这个故事。它在我的骨髓里。我不想等一年。我不想让这种感觉减弱或消散。你能接手《侏罗纪公园》剩下的部分吗？所以乔治同意了，乔治为这部电影混音并校正了颜色。
And it had already been cut. I had locked the cut, but George did everything else after the law cut. And that allowed me the freedom to go off and start. I mean, you know, and the confidence that you've always had, I mean, I remember that documentary talking about called Spielberg, which is so great, that you said when you were much younger and making your first films, once you finished one movie, you couldn't wait to start another because you felt good about yourself when you were making films. And when you weren't making anything, you know, you had to be with yourself and reflect
它已经被剪辑过了。我锁定了剪辑，但乔治在最终剪辑之后做了其他所有事情。这给了我离开并开始的自由。我的意思是，你知道的，你一直都有的那种自信，我的意思是，我记得那部名为《斯皮尔伯格》的纪录片，太棒了，你说过当你年轻得多、拍第一部电影时，一旦你完成了一部电影，你就迫不及待地想开始下一部，因为当你拍电影时你对自己感觉很好。而当你什么都没拍时，你知道，你必须和自己相处并反思
on who you were, the doubt that, as you called them, the scary whispers of lack of self-esteem or whatever it is. Do those, when did those feeling, I'm sure they don't creep in anymore. I mean, look at you, but how and when did that shift for you where you became, you know what? I'm going to trust the moments in between movies. That's never, I've never taken that, that beautiful pill. That's never happened for me.
你是谁，那些你所谓的缺乏自尊的恐惧低语或其他什么。那些，那些感觉是什么时候，我确信它们不再潜入了。我的意思是，看看你，但是那种转变是如何以及何时对你发生的，让你变成，你知道吗？我要信任电影之间的那些时光。那从没有，我从没吃过那颗美丽的药丸。那从未发生在我身上。
I mean, oh my God, I wish that would have happened for me. No, fear is my fuel. I've often said that. And it's true. The scarier I get, the sort of more proactive I become and I get more inspired. If I'm not secure, if I'm really secure, look at my sequels are not as good as the originals because I know at least it's going to open, you know, it's going to open really well. And so-
我的意思是，天哪，我希望那曾发生在我身上。不，恐惧是我的动力。我经常这样说。这是真的。我越害怕，我就会变得越主动，我就会得到更多的灵感。如果我不安全，如果我真的安全，看看我的续集没有原作那么好，因为我知道至少它会上映，你知道，它会上映得很好。所以——
But you had the confidence not to make Jaws 2, which is, I don't understand. Yes, I did. I had the confidence not to make Jaws 2. And I didn't think there should have been a Jaws 2. You know, I don't know if there's an answer for this, but if there is one, you'd be the one to be able to come up with it. It seems like every year the distance between the films that get great reviews versus the films that make a lot of money gets further.
但你有不拍《大白鲨2》的自信，我不明白。是的，我有了。我有不拍《大白鲨2》的自信。而且我认为不应该有《大白鲨2》。你知道，我不知道这有没有答案，但如果有的话，你将是那个能够想出答案的人。似乎每年获得好评的电影与票房大卖的电影之间的距离越来越远。
And you have seamlessly been able to marry both commercial viability and artistic accolades in every film that you do. It's just, it's an incredible accomplishment. What would you say to a filmmaker that was looking to, you know, make money with a film or, you know, be commercial, sell popcorn, but also really impressed the most discerning of critics, viewers, et cetera. What is that, what is that ratio? What's that sauce that it's not this, it's not that, it's together?
而你却能够在拍的每一部电影中天衣无缝地将商业可行性和艺术赞誉结合在一起。这简直是一个了不起的成就。你会对一个想要，你知道的，通过电影赚钱，或者说，你知道，具有商业性、卖爆米花，但同时也真正打动最挑剔的评论家、观众等的电影制作人说些什么？那个比例是多少？那个秘诀是什么，它不是这个，它不是那个，而是结合在一起？
I mean, I think every filmmaker needs to make a movie that that filmmaker would not be able to live without making, would not be able to live without in their lives. So the first, the first person the filmmaker has to please is him or herself. I mean, that's absolutely essential that you've got to do something, you know, right for you. Then you have to, of course, be responsible and you don't want to overspend and you want to control the budget as much as possible. If the film doesn't feel like a commercial movie on the outset, you want to spend a ton of money, it was not going to make a money back for the studio because often it's the
我的意思是，我认为每个电影制作人都需要拍一部这个电影制作人不拍就无法活下去的电影，没有它就无法在生活中活下去。所以，电影制作人首先要取悦的人是他或她自己。我的意思是，这绝对是必不可少的，你必须做一些，你知道的，对你来说正确的事情。然后你必须，当然，要负起责任，你不想超支，你想尽可能控制预算。如果电影一开始感觉不像一部商业电影，你想花一大笔钱，它就不会为工作室把钱赚回来，因为通常
commercial success is something that gives you your second job. Or if the film gets great reviews, by the way, and doesn't make any money, that could also get you your second job. But you've got to please yourself before you try to please the studio or try to please the critics. You've got to say, you know, if nobody goes to see this movie and if nobody really writes nice things about it, but if I like it and I could live with the story I told and the work in that story, that's good enough for me, and that should be the main criterion
商业上的成功是给你带来第二份工作的东西。或者如果这部电影获得了极好的评价，顺便说一句，却没有赚钱，那也能为你赢得第二份工作。但在你试图取悦工作室或试图取悦评论家之前，你必须取悦自己。你必须说，你知道，如果没有人去看这部电影，如果没有人真正写出关于它的好评，但如果我喜欢它，我能接受我讲的故事以及那个故事中的工作，这就足够好了，这应该成为主要的标准
for filmmakers. Right. Right. So the story, so you're not thinking, I need to do this to achieve this, you know, so that it's viewed by other people in a certain way and how they feel about it is secondary to how I feel about it. And that's where I'm going to- That's exactly right.
对于电影制作人来说。对。对。所以这个故事，所以你不是在想，我需要这样做来实现这个，你知道的，让其他人以某种特定的方式来看待它，他们对它的感觉是次要的，我对它的感觉才是主要的。这就是我要去的——完全正确。
But if you want to make commercial movies, then what are you going to go for first? A high concept. Right. You want to get into the high concept business and you're going to want to do something that's already been proven to have been successful. And the kind of movies I really admire are the films that nobody ever guessed would make any money at all. They make a lot of money.
但如果你想拍商业电影，那么你首先会追求什么？高概念。对。你想进入高概念行业，你会想要做一些已经被证明是成功的事情。而我真正钦佩的电影是那些没有人会猜到能赚钱的电影。它们赚了大钱。
You know, that's always really, really, something like that happens, that's very exciting. It seems like, lucky for us, what you seem to think is commercially viable or is super relatable, ends up being very, very human stories, which is a great guess as to what is going to be commercially appealing is something that we can all relate to. Something we're all human, we all have parents, we all, there's a small little person inside of all of us that we've been with since we were little kids that no matter how old you get, it's still there. And you always seem to-
你知道，这总是真的，真的，当这样的事情发生时，这非常令人兴奋。似乎，幸运的是，你认为具有商业可行性或超级引起共鸣的东西，最终变成了非常非常有人情味的故事，这是一个很好的猜测，关于什么将具有商业吸引力，那就是我们都能感同身受的东西。我们都是人类，我们都有父母，在我们所有人内心深处都有一个小人儿，自从我们还是小孩子起就一直陪着我们，不管你多大年纪，它依然在那里。而你似乎总是——
Little janky baits. Yeah, little janky baits. It seems like they're at the center of all of your stories, no matter whether they're big movies or small movies or black and white or color or effects or not, there is something that you just drill us right in the chest. And just thank you for that, no question in that. Thank you, yeah. Thank you very much.
小淘气们。是的，小淘气们。似乎它们是你所有故事的核心，无论它们是大电影还是小电影，黑白还是彩色，有特效还是没有特效，总有一些东西能直击我们的胸膛。为此谢谢你，这其中没有任何疑问。谢谢，是的。非常感谢。
Do you have a, Jason kind of touched on this already, and we've asked this, we've kind of talked about this area a lot on our show, but does it bum you out that certain films you may be drawn to direct would be for streaming and not the theater now, like that whole argument of like the movies that used to be in the theater are now on our TV? When you say bum me out, are you talking about my own work and the choices I make too? Sure, but in terms of the business as a whole. Well the streaming business has given a chance for five times more filmmakers to get their start making films than had there never been a streaming business.
你有没有，杰森之前已经触及过这个了，我们已经问过了，我们已经在节目中讨论过很多这个领域，但某些你可能被吸引去执导的电影现在会是为了流媒体而不是为了影院上映，这会让你感到沮丧吗，就像那种“过去在影院上映的电影现在在我们的电视上”的争论？当你问是不是让我沮丧时，你是在说我自己的工作和我做出的选择吗？当然，但就整个行业而言。嗯，流媒体行业给初次拍电影的电影制作人提供了比如果没有流媒体行业多五倍的机会。
Yeah, that's true. In a way, it is a huge opportunity for storytellers to get their feet wet. And if they have a good idea, they find a book and a streaming service wants it and the person's only done music videos or the person's only done commercials or the person's just on someone else's recommendation that the streaming service trusts or an actor says, I want this person to direct me. It's a great way to get started in this business, my God, if we had streaming services back when I was starting out, a lot more filmmakers would have gotten their breaks.
是的，这是真的。在某种程度上，这对讲故事的人来说是一个绝佳的机会，让他们可以牛刀小试。如果他们有一个好想法，他们找到了一本书，而一个流媒体服务想要它，而这个人只拍过音乐录影带，或者这个人只拍过商业广告，或者这个人只是基于流媒体服务信任的某人的推荐，或者一个演员说，我想要这个人来导演我。这是在这个行业里开始的一个绝佳方式，天哪，如果我在刚开始时有流媒体服务，会有更多的电影制作人得到他们的突破。
So I think the streaming services are very, very good. What I would like to see the streaming services do, however, is to allow more theatrical window dressing so that they're at least given a chance to make some of their money back theatrically where people can go out to the movies and see them before they debut on the service. And I think if you come out with a movie that is popular or at least is critically popular, if not commercially popular, you build up the IP, you build up a cache is created. And so the film becomes kind of famous. So when it comes on the streaming service, debuts three weeks, six weeks later, it's
所以我认为流媒体服务非常好。然而，我希望看到流媒体服务做的是，提供更多的院线窗口期，这样它们至少有机会在院线收回一些成本，人们可以在它们在流媒体上首播之前出去看电影。而且我认为如果你推出一部受欢迎的电影，或者至少在影评上受欢迎，如果不算商业上受欢迎的话，你积累了IP，你建立了一种声誉。所以这部电影变得有点出名了。因此，当它在流媒体服务上播出时，三周、六周后首播，它是
recognizable and people say, oh, I've heard all about that. Wow. I want to see that. And so I don't understand the day and date philosophy, which is why I'd be terrible running a streaming service and why I'd probably get fired the first day. Well, one of the other things that streaming has given us an opportunity for, as viewers and filmmakers, is the more of the long form approach to these stories. And I'm sure that you've answered this, so I apologize for not knowing your answer.
具有辨识度的，人们会说，哦，我听说过这个。哇。我想看那个。所以我不理解“同步首播”（day and date）的哲学，这就是为什么我运营流媒体服务会糟糕透顶，为什么我可能会在第一天就被解雇。嗯，流媒体带给我们的另一个机会，作为观众和电影制作人，是针对这些故事采用更多长篇形式的方法。我确信你已经回答过这个问题了，所以如果我不知道你的答案，我深表歉意。
But if you wouldn't mind repeating it, your instinct or appetite for doing something that is perhaps a limited series, some sort of an eight-hour story as opposed to a two-hour story, where do you sit on that? I'm sure you play with certain ideas. I was willing to do Lincoln as a six-hour because I couldn't raise all the financing for it. Nobody believed in it. Our company was only good for 50% of the budget, and I went all around town and everybody
但如果你不介意重复一下，你对制作某种类似于限定剧、某种八小时的故事而不是两小时的故事的直觉或胃口如何，你对此怎么看？我确信你玩味过某些想法。我曾愿意把《林肯》拍成六小时的，因为我筹集不到全部资金。没有人相信它。我们公司只能承担50%的预算，我跑遍了全城，每个人都
turned me down. I'm not going to name names, but every single person turned me down. And I was ready to make a deal with HVO to do it, to expand it to six hours. Tony Kushner's first draft was 550 pages, so I had the goods, I had the material. I don't know if I could talk Daniel Day-Lewis into doing five or six hours, but I was on the brink of that, and the person that came in at the 11th hour and sort of saved it for the movie screen was Tom Rothman over at 20th Century Fox. And he read the script, and he put up the other half of the money, and that's why the
拒绝了我。我不打算点名，但每一个人都拒绝了我。我准备和HBO达成协议来做这件事，把它扩展到六小时。托尼·库什纳（Tony Kushner）的第一稿是550页，所以我手里有货，我有素材。我不知道我能否说服丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯（Daniel Day-Lewis）演五到六个小时，但我当时已经到了边缘，而在最后关头进来并在电影银幕上拯救了它的人是二十世纪福克斯的汤姆·罗斯曼（Tom Rothman）。他读了剧本，出资买下了另一半，这就是为什么这部
film became a feature film. Wow, that's pretty cool. Do you have an appetite at all? I do have an appetite for long form, and I someday will direct a long form series. I mean, if somebody had brought me, Marivistown, I would have done that. That was a beautifully directed story. I love that. Great.
电影成为了一部故事片。哇，这太酷了。你对长篇形式有一点兴趣吗？我确实对长篇形式有兴趣，总有一天我会执导一部长篇剧集。我的意思是，如果有人拿来《东城梦魇》（Mare of Easttown），我就会拍那个。那是一个导演得非常美丽的故事。我喜欢那个。太棒了。
Let me get an email address on you real quick. Hey, Stephen, so Fableman's is the movie that you always wanted to make. It's the story. Is there another story out there? Is there another thing out there that you're like, nobody will ever make it, or this is improbable, or like, but it's something that's always kind of, I don't know, maybe something you read years ago that you've always like, God, maybe there's a world where I could make that.
让我快速记下你的电子邮箱。嘿，史蒂文，所以《造梦之家》是你一直想拍的电影。它是这个故事。还有另一个故事吗？还有其他事情是你觉得，没有人会拍它，或者这不太可能，或者像，但它一直是那种，我不知道，也许是你几年前读过的东西，你一直觉得，天哪，也许有一个世界我可以拍那个。
Is there one out there? If there was, I wouldn't be talking to you guys. I'd be on location somewhere shooting it, and I would say, I'll do it next year when I'm available. I'll talk to you guys next year because I love you so much, your posture so much. No, I don't. I actually haven't crossed that bridge yet. I don't have what you would call the next film I've always wanted to make.
有这样的东西吗？如果有的话，我就不会和你们说话了。我会去某个地方的外景地拍摄，我会说，我明年有空时会拍。我明年会和你们谈，因为我太爱你们了，太爱你们的立场了。不，我没有。我实际上还没过那个桥。我没有那种你可以称之为我一直想拍的下一部电影的东西。
West Side Story fulfilled a deep, abiding love of the idiom of the Hollywood and the Broadway musical, and it was the only musical I would ever turn into a movie. And not to say that I didn't love the 61 movie, I adore the 61 movie, but Tony Kushner and I found a way to make it relevant for today, for our time, and that's why I did it. I didn't have any desire or appetite to make another musical. That was it for me. But I don't have a wish list that goes much beyond the Fablemen's as my personal kind
《西区故事》满足了我对好莱坞和百老汇音乐剧习语的深沉、持久的热爱，它是我唯一会拍成电影的音乐剧。并不是说我不喜欢61年的电影，我崇拜61年的电影，但托尼·库什纳和我找到了一种让它与今天、我们的时代相关的方式，这就是我拍它的原因。我没有再拍一部音乐剧的欲望或胃口。对我来说就是这样。但我没有一个愿望清单远远超出《造梦之家》，作为我对我家人的个人情书，而且不仅是对我生命中那些霸凌者的小情书。
of love letter to my family, and not so much a little love letter for the bullies in my life. But I was able to work out the trauma because I think we all work out trauma through the art we create. That's how you work out the trauma. By the way, one of the greatest lines in the Fablemen's is when the bully is bullying you in the hallway and you say, maybe I'll make a movie about it one day. It's like, we're watching that movie, it was so cool.
但我能够克服创伤，因为我认为我们都是通过我们创造的艺术来克服创伤的。这就是你克服创伤的方式。顺便说一句，《造梦之家》中最棒的台词之一就是那个霸凌者在走廊里欺负你，而你说，也许我有一天会拍一部关于它的电影。就像，我们在看那部电影，太酷了。
You mentioned West Side Story. Can I ask you about the choreography in that was just so exciting. Incredible. Incredible. Not only just the dancing and the actual design of the choreography, but the way in which you guys shot that, sorry to ask another process question about, you know, shot design and cover strategy. But what was the call time on that?
你提到了《西区故事》。我能问你其中的编舞吗，真是太激动人心了。不可思议。不可思议。不仅是舞蹈和编舞本身的实际设计，还有你们拍摄的方式，抱歉又要问一个关于流程的问题，关于镜头设计和覆盖策略。那里的集合时间是什么时候？
Sorry. I didn't really like to get into the nitty. But it did seem to me like the choreography had to happen first, and then you and your cinematographer, was that Janusz as well? Janusz Kraminski. And so would you guys watch these dances fully done and then decide how you're going to shoot it? Yes.
抱歉。我其实不太喜欢卷入繁琐的细节。但对我来说，编舞似乎必须先发生，然后你和你的摄影师，那也是亚努什吗？亚努什·卡明斯基（Janusz Kaminski）。所以你们会看完这些完全跳完的舞蹈，然后决定如何拍摄吗？是的。
I would watch the dances fully done. The first thing I did was I storyboarded the choreography. So I sat down just with a pencil, and I sat with Justin Peck and I did the whole thing on paper. I went to Justin's office. He's the choreographer with his associate, now his wife, Patricia Delgado. And I just started, we put on the Broadway, 57 Broadway, you know, score, the Broadway album.
我会看完这些完全跳完的舞蹈。我做的第一件事是把编舞画成故事板。所以我只是拿着铅笔坐下来，我和贾斯汀·佩克（Justin Peck）坐在一起，在纸上完成了整件事。我去了贾斯汀的办公室。他是编舞，和他的合伙人、现在他的妻子帕特丽夏·德尔加多（Patricia Delgado）在一起。我刚开始，我们播放了百老汇的，57号百老汇的，你知道的，总谱，百老汇专辑。
And I basically used the Broadway album and I just started doing shots and I just started doing, figuring out what could be a sustained shot where all the dancing could take place in front of your eyes, before your eyes, so it doesn't seem cheated. It's all happening right before you and what things needed, these staccato energy infused of montage, of editing. And I figured that out. But then when Justin started choreographing it, I'd go down to Dumbo, Brooklyn and I would just watch him put all these numbers on their feet and I took my iPhone.
我基本上用了百老汇的专辑，然后开始拍摄镜头，弄清楚哪些镜头可以持续进行，并且所有舞蹈都可以在你眼前发生，这样就不会显得作假。这一切都在你眼前发生，以及哪些部分需要蒙太奇和剪辑带来的那种断续而充满活力的能量。我弄明白了。但后来当贾斯汀开始编舞时，我去了布鲁克林丹波区，看着他把这些歌舞排练起来，我拿出了我的iPhone。
And guys, I just basically shot every number up with my iPhone by myself. I'd be sometimes in a chair with forecasters and they'd dolly me around, but I got all my shots on my iPhone. I would cut it together to the music and then realize, well, that sucked. And I would go back the next day and I would reshoot the whole thing on my iPhone and because he kept repeating the choreography and he kept fine-tuning it. I was able to make six, seven passes and cut all those passes together with my camera device.
伙计们，我基本上就是用我的iPhone一个人拍下了每一个歌舞片段。有时我会坐在装有脚轮的椅子上，他们推着我到处走，但我所有的镜头都是用iPhone拍的。我会把它剪辑到音乐中，然后意识到，嗯，这太烂了。第二天我会回去，用我的iPhone重新拍摄整段内容，因为他一直在重复编舞，并且不断微调。我能够拍六、七个版本，然后用我的拍摄设备把所有这些版本剪辑在一起。
Wow. So by the time I got to the stage or the time I got to the streets of Brooklyn and the streets of Paterson, New Jersey and down to Harlem where we shot a lot of the film, it had already been shot on video and I just went and converted that to film. By the way, Tim Cook is going to request the tapes from this for his new iPhone commercial. Yeah, exactly. I want to ask you one of my favorite moments and a lot of people, but one of my, to me, a profoundly funny, great moment.
哇。所以当我到达片场，或者当我到达布鲁克林的街道、新泽西州帕特森的街道以及我们拍摄了大量电影的哈莱姆区时，它其实已经用视频拍过了，我只是去把它转成了电影。顺便说一句，蒂姆·库克将会为他的新iPhone广告向索要这些录像带。对，没错。我想问你一个我最喜欢的时刻，也是很多人的最深刻、最有趣、最棒的时刻。
I want to know how much of it was planned before or how long before is that great moment in Indiana Jones when the guy pulls out the knife and the sword and he starts swinging around and Harrison Ford just pulls out his gun and shoots him and not only just shoots him, then turns away and like back to business. To me, it's profoundly funny that everything about it is great. And then beautifully recalled in the end of the trailer of the new film. That's right. Yeah.
我想知道在那之前计划了多少，或者在《夺宝奇兵》中那个精彩时刻发生前多久，那个家伙掏出刀剑开始挥舞，而哈里森·福特只是掏出枪把他给射了，而且不仅是射了他，还转过身去就像什么事都没发生一样继续工作。对我来说，这极其搞笑，各个方面都很棒。而且在最后新电影预告片的结尾被巧妙地致敬了。没错。对。
It's recalled. I think what's funny about that, and I'll tell you in a second how that came about, but I think what's funny about that is the last thing he does when the swordsman threatens him, and I felt this was really important. I asked Harrison to wipe his brow and in so doing, fold the front of his fedora hat upwards. So he looks a bit like Gabby Hayes. And I thought by making him look a little funny looking by taking the brim of his fedora and, and forcing it to go up as opposed to coolly be down just over the brow, it took
这是对过去的呼应。我觉得有趣的是——一会儿我会告诉你这是怎么来的——我觉得有趣的是，当那个剑客威胁他时，他做的最后一件我觉得非常重要的事情。我让哈里森擦了擦额头，并在这样做的时候，把他的软呢帽檐向上翻起。所以他看起来有点像加比·海耶斯。我想通过把他的软呢帽檐向上翻，而不是让它很酷地压在眉毛上方，让他看起来有点滑稽，这样它就...
the onus off of cold blood and murder. Right. That was a little thing that I was hoping would work for us. But the whole reason it, it happened was Harrison, you know, had some tainted lamb the night before at a, at a, at a restaurant in where we were shooting in caravan, Tunisia. And he had some tainted lamb and he had a case of what we call the teristas. And he said that morning, he said, you only got an hour. I'm going back to the hotel in an hour.
减轻了冷血谋杀的嫌疑。对吧。那是我希望对我们有帮助的一个小细节。但这一切发生的原因是，哈里森前一天晚上在突尼斯凯鲁万我们拍摄地的一家餐厅吃了一点变质的羊肉。他吃了变质的羊肉，得了我们所谓的“特里斯坦斯”（腹泻）。那天早上他说，你只有一小时。我一个小时后就要回酒店了。
What can you do in an hour? And I said, but it's a three page scene between a swordsman and a whip. You're supposed to fight this guy with your bullwhip. He said, yeah, but you only got an hour. And I remember saying, well, why don't we just shoot the guy? And Harrison remembers saying to me, why don't we just shoot the guy? So I don't know whose idea it was, but I know it was one of the two of us came up with the idea.
一个小时你能做什么？我说，但这是一个剑客和一条鞭子之间三页纸的戏啊。你应该用你的牛鞭和这家伙打。他说，对，但你只有一个小时。我记得当时说，那我们为什么不直接一枪崩了那家伙呢？哈里森也记得他对我说过，我们为什么不直接一枪崩了那家伙呢？所以我不知道这到底是谁的主意，但我知道这是我们俩中的一个想出来的。
And I, and we, and about an hour and a half later, we had done four shots and he went back to the hotel. Wow. That's amazing. That's amazing. When I corner Jason at a party, sometimes he calls me Gabby Hayes. Anyway. So I have one question about nobody's going to know who Gabby Hayes is.
而且我，我们，大约一个半小时后，我们拍了四个镜头，他就回酒店了。哇。太惊人了。太惊人了。当我在派对上把杰森逼入绝境时，有时他会叫我加比·海耶斯。不管怎样。所以，我有一个关于——没人会知道加比·海耶斯是谁的。
I know, but one question about, and then we'll let you go cause I don't want to take up too much of your time. John Williams. Okay. So John Williams been nominated for 52 Academy Awards for all of his scores. It's unbelievable. It's like, but the Fableman's was more than Campbell soup, make soup. But your collaboration with him in the Fableman's, as he now famously has made it known that
我知道，但有一个关于——然后我们就让你走，因为我不想占用你太多时间。约翰·威廉姆斯。好吧。所以约翰·威廉姆斯曾52次获得奥斯卡最佳原创音乐提名。这太不可思议了。这就像，但《造梦之家》得到的比坎贝尔汤生产的汤还要多。但是你和他在《造梦之家》中的合作，正如他现在广为人知的那样...
he's retiring from film scoring. Tell me what that was like, knowing, sitting in those sessions with him, knowing that this is going to be your last collaboration together. Right. Well, you know, he, we collaborated on Indiana Jones five, which just finished and that'll be his last film score, which I'm, I'm, you know, emeritus now I'm executive producer, no longer directing Jim Mangles, the director and, and, but for the Fableman's that was going to be the last score that he was going to write for me as director.
他将从电影配乐界退休。告诉我那是怎样的感受，坐在那些录音室里，知道这将是你们最后一次合作。对。好吧，你知道，我们合作了刚刚完成的《夺宝奇兵5》，那将是他的最后一部电影配乐，我现在已经是名誉制作人了，我是执行制片人，不再执导了，詹姆士·曼高德是导演，但是对于《造梦之家》，这将是他作为导演为我写的最后一部配乐。
And we, I knew that going in and Johnny did something very special. I mean, he always previews the scores for me, but he had to come up with a tune. We only play one time, which is in the last scene between Mitzi and her son, Sammy. The last scene they have together in the film and John composed it just for that scene. And then of course it recalls itself in the end titles. You have to hear it a second time over the end credits, but it was one of the loveliest pieces of music he has ever written for any of my movies. And he did it as a gift to my mom and to my dad and to me.
而且我们在开始之前就知道这一点，约翰尼做了一件非常特别的事。我的意思是，他总是先为我试听配乐，但他必须创作一段旋律。我们只演奏一次，就是在米齐和她的儿子萨米之间的最后一场戏中。他们在电影中在一起的最后一场戏，约翰专门为那场戏谱了曲。然后当然它在片尾字幕中再次响起。你必须在片尾字幕中第二次听到它，但这是他为我的任何电影写过的最可爱的音乐之一。他是作为送给我妈妈、我爸爸和我的礼物创作的。
And I'll never forget it and I'll never forget my reaction to it. And the other only, I had a lot of very emotional reactions to Johnny's music, but the only thing that this reminded me of was when he wrote the main theme from Schindler's list and how, how deeply moved I was. And then it happened again less than a year ago when he previewed the score on the piano. Yeah. It's one of the greatest collaborations ever, you two, for how many movies it's just incredible. It's my, it's, it's the greatest collaboration I've ever had in, in my career ever.
我永远不会忘记它，也永远不会忘记我当时对它的反应。另外，对于约翰尼的音乐，我有很多非常情绪化的反应，但这让我想起的唯一一件事就是他写《辛德勒的名单》的主题曲时，我是多么的深受感动。然后不到一年前，当他在钢琴上试听配乐时，这种感觉又发生了。是的。这是有史以来最伟大的合作之一，你们两个，拍了那么多电影，简直不可思议。这是我，在我整个职业生涯中经历过的最伟大的合作。
Wow. Yeah. It's insane. Which is saying a lot. Yeah. I've had a lot of great collaborations, but that one takes the cake. Yeah. Well, we haven't, we haven't worked together yet, but that's okay.
哇。是的。这太疯狂了。这话分量很重。是的。我有过很多伟大的合作，但那一次绝对是独占鳌头。是的。嗯，我们还没合作过呢，不过没关系。
But anyway. That's coming. That's coming. That'll be one of the great ones. Check your emails, Sean. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
但不管怎样。那就要来了。那就要来了。那将是伟大的合作之一。查查你的邮件，肖恩。对。对。对。
For sure. Stephen, thank you for your time. I could ask you 75,000 more questions, but you're very, very kind to give us even this, this little bit of time. This flew by for me. Thank you for the best time talking to all three of you. Stephen, we so appreciate it. Thank you so much.
真的。斯蒂芬，谢谢你抽出时间。我可以再问你7万个问题，但你非常非常善良，能给我们哪怕这么一点点时间。对我来说，时间飞逝。谢谢你和你们三个人度过了一段最美好的交谈时光。斯蒂芬，我们非常感激。非常感谢。
Thank you so much. Thank you so much. Please keep going. Thanks, pal. All right. And Jason, Jason, keep directing. I love your Ozark episodes. I love all your work.
非常感谢。非常感谢。请继续。谢谢你，伙计。好的。还有杰森，杰森，继续导演吧。我很喜欢你的《黑钱胜地》剧集。我喜欢你的所有作品。
Thank you. Thank you very much. Thank you so much. Sean, good luck on Broadway and Will. Good luck with everything that you do. And I just, I'm just very honored that you three guys chose me to talk to you. That's so sweet. Thank you so much.
谢谢。非常感谢。非常感谢。肖恩，祝你在百老汇一切顺利，威尔。祝你所做的一切都顺利。我只是，我非常荣幸你们三个人选择我来接受采访。太贴心了。非常感谢。
Thank you, Stephen. Very much. Have a great day. You too. Thank you. Bye. Thank you. Yeah.
谢谢你，斯蒂芬。非常感谢。祝你有美好的一天。你也是。谢谢。再见。谢谢。对。
Who wants to start crying first? I did. I did just a little bit already. I did. I would say, I will say this to one of the, first of all, how incredible that we got to sit and have an hour talking with Steven Spielberg. I mean, Sean, I think you win the, the, the, the, the, the guest, the guest grab of the, of the year.
谁想先开始哭？我哭了。我刚才已经稍微哭了一点。我哭了。我会说，我要对其中一个——首先，能坐下来和史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格聊上一个小时，是多么不可思议的事啊。我的意思是，肖恩，我觉得你赢得了年度最佳嘉宾奖。
Was he on your guys' list too? Well, yeah, but I wouldn't ever dream of pitching him as like, hey, let's call Steven more of, of guests that I was like, you know, here's the other thing I can mention. And I want to say this is, is that when we got, when we were finished interviewing him, and we can cut this if we want, but we were able to talk to him for a few minutes after we, you know, we stopped rolling for a second. Yeah. And he said goodbye to us and to have that moment of, which we don't generally have with
他也在你们的名单上吗？嗯，是的，但我永远不会梦想着向他推销，比如，嘿，让我们打电话给史蒂芬，更多的是我觉得，你知道，这里还有一件事我可以提。我想说的是，当我们完成采访时——如果我们愿意的话，这段可以剪掉——但在我们停止录音后的一会儿，我们还能和他交谈几分钟。对。他向我们道别，并且有了那样的一个时刻——我们通常没有...
people. Never, by the way. Never, never, never. Never, never, never. We stopped for a second and we started talking to him. And he made this sort of the, he made a point to go around and ask each one of us what, what was going on. And how,
顺便说一句，从来没有。从来没有，从来没有。从来没有，从来没有，从来没有。我们停了一会儿，开始和他说话。他特意走过来问我们每个人，最近在忙什么。以及，
I know. And like, So kind. Yeah. And very kind and generous of spirit and really sweet guy. Yeah. He's got that, I mean, he's got that thing that not a lot of people have where he checks a lot of boxes just in this business of being an incredibly talented man, a personable guy
我知道。而且像，太友善了。是的。非常有善心，慷慨大度，真的是个很甜的家伙。杰森。是的。他拥有那种——我的意思是，他拥有那种很多人不具备的特质，在这个行业里，他在很多方面都表现得无可挑剔，既是一个非常有才华的人，又是一个平易近人的人，
a people person, like social skills are incredible. Yeah. Like he and the town. Right. Because these are stuff you should strive for. I'm looking up. I'm saying them. I know.
善于交际的人，社交技能简直不可思议。是的。就像他和这个小镇一样。对。因为这些都是你应该努力去争取的东西。我正在抬头看。我正在说它们。我知道。
People person. That requires going around people. You have to be around other people. He does seem incredibly generous with the, the presence that he, he seems to be aware that he has with, with folks and he's not, he doesn't take that for granted. And he was, So he was really generous with us. And as you said,
善于交际的人。这需要经常与人接触。你必须和别人在一起。他似乎对自己的存在感非常慷慨，他似乎意识到自己在人们面前有着怎样的影响力，而且他并不把这当作理所当然。所以他对我们非常慷慨。正如你所说，
Will made it a point to make sure that he just said, Hey, how things going on in, in your life and how important that would be to him. Well, and Jason, you said it too, it's hard for him to ignore who he is. He knows who he is and where he fits within the sort of the, you know, certainly like I said to him on the show, culturally, the impact that he has had. And the other thing is, you know, like I said, you know, he was very generous. I told him the story of, and you guys know this when I came, when we were shooting Blades of Glory and he, we made it for DreamWorks and he had seen the first dailies and I was
威尔特意确保他只是说，嘿，你生活中最近怎么样，这对他来说有多重要。嗯，还有杰森，你也说过了，他很难忽视自己是谁。他知道他是谁，以及他在文化上所产生的影响——正如我在节目中对他说的那样，他在文化上产生了巨大的影响。另一件事是，你知道，就像我说的，他非常慷慨。我告诉过他一个故事，你们也知道，当我来的时候，当时我们正在拍摄《冰刀双人组》，这是我们为梦工厂拍的，他看过第一天的粗剪片段，我当时...
coming out of SNL with, it was Sudeikis and Will Forte and we were talking after SNL and this was like 2006, I guess. And the winter of 2006 and we're standing there waiting to go to the after party in Spielberg, Steven Spielberg walks into our little crew of guys were talking, waiting to get in the car, go to the after party and he goes, hey, Will, Steven Spielberg, I just want to say I've seen the dailies of Blades of Glory and you're doing such a terrific job. And then disappeared into the night gun in the car and drove away. And I remember Sudeikis and Forte being like, what the fuck, man?
刚从《周六夜现场》出来，当时有苏戴奇斯和威尔·福特，我们在《周六夜现场》结束后聊天，这大概是2006年吧。2006年的冬天，我们站在那里等着去庆功派对，斯皮尔伯格、史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格走进了我们这一小群聊天的人中间，我们正等着上车去庆功派对，他说，嘿，威尔，我是史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格，我只是想说我看了《冰刀双人组》的粗剪片段，你表现得太棒了。然后他就消失在夜色中，上车开走了。我记得苏戴奇斯和福特当时都惊呆了，觉得，搞什么鬼，伙计？
Like did that just happen? And it was such a, and he didn't need to do that. He didn't need to go out of his way. He knows who he is. He understands the impact for me as a, you know, as a performer, as a thing of like, it was mind blowing. I was, I was, he lifted me up and I think that that's what he does. He lifts people up and when you're, you live your life in the service of lifting other
就像，刚刚发生什么了？这真是个——他本不必这么做的。他本不必特意这样做。他知道他是谁。他理解这对我作为一个表演者、作为一个个体所产生的影响——这太震撼了。我当时，我被他鼓励了，我觉得这就是他所做的。他鼓励别人，当你的一生都在致力于鼓励其他人时，
people up, you, you get to, you know, it lists your own spirit. Yeah, it's incredible, man. Incredible. If you have like a light bulb to change or a picture to hang, you have to lift people up. I think that you're going a little, you know what you are? You know what, Sean? Yeah.
你，你就会——这也会提升你自己的精神。是的，太不可思议了，伙计。不可思议。如果你有什么灯泡要换或者有什么画要挂，你必须把人抬起来。我觉得你有点——你知道你是什么吗？你知道吗，肖恩？是的。
I mean, I don't mind it, but you're, that's a little, bye, the book. Bye. Well done. Smart. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grand Terry, Rob Armjärv and Bennett barbecue. Smart loss. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it
我的意思是，我不介意，但你那个，有点太按部就班了。好吧。干得好。聪明。聪明。Smartless 节目是 100% 有机的，由迈克尔·格兰特里、罗布·阿尔姆耶夫和贝内特烧烤店手工制作。Smartless。我们的下一期节目将在一个一周内发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你也可以收听...
right now, early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在，在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过在苹果播客或汪迪应用上订阅 Wondry Plus 来提前收听且无广告。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。